[Music]
homie look what I become
so so our guest today is kind of a big
deal okay I mean if you go on YouTube
You're gonna find this stuff he's all
over the place he's allowed he makes
people think he pisses people off he's
got a following some days you love him
some days you hate them but no matter
what you're thinking about this guy and
he's got another guy Ian uh uh uh
Moon Lord I'm learning about you as well
you're 44 years old which is an
incredible age very very good age but
let me introduce Our Guest Temple uh his
background he is an American political
commentator and podcast host who first
became known for live streaming the 2011
Occupy Wall Street protest he joined
Vice media and fusion TV in 2014 later
working alone on YouTube and other
platforms by the way this guy went from
saying he's not a journalist he's an
activist and he said he's an actor he's
a journalist not an activist he was a
Bernie guy he's no longer Bernie guy one
you know he'll support Trump so so the
best part about him that's the best part
about a journey that somebody will go
through through as you're getting your
political ideas in place is to follow
that journey to see how you evolve from
you believing in this to this to that
what caused that change I'm going to
talk about that on top of that we have
to discuss uh what happened with Kanye
West firing Nick Fuentes I want to get
you inside on that and replacing with
Milo I think Milo actually made the
phone call we'll talk about Tucker
whether it was a deep fake what they're
doing to attack him uh your Pat your
background in doing Occupy Wall Street
what that was like we'll talk about
Bernie Sanders RFK what Ron Paul said
about you know John F Kennedy
assassination Vice what is going on with
a 5.7 billion dollar company potentially
going out of business but having said
that thanks for coming out man it's good
to have you yeah thanks for having me
how you doing I'm doing good doing doing
well well doing well that's good yeah
how's Florida treating you since you've
been here for like seven hours eight
hours uh it's been okay you know your
rental car rental didn't pull through so
it's like we get here at two in the
morning and then I'm just like half
asleep welcome to Florida baby you're a
big DeSantis guy is what I like big
supportive of Santa's Jimmy Jennings
in a big way so we'll cover that as well
but for some of the folks that don't
know take a couple minutes kind of share
your background how the whole thing from
the beginning you know to where you're
at today well it all started in 1986
back in uh
seven years ago West Virginia yeah look
down I'm from Chicago oh sure and uh
yeah shy town and uh South Side family
uh
around the Midwest area my mom's from St
Louis but um I were I started listening
to punk rock music when I was a kid
because for whatever reason it was
popular which got me more involved in
politics I think the internet got me
more involved in politics I'm a young
teenager online seeing news articles pop
up reading about this stuff and then I
started working for non-profits when I'm
uh when I was around 20 years old trying
to do activism I was you know listening
all the punk rock stuff made me very
political started working with
nonprofits thinking like this is the way
we're going to change the world and uh
quickly realize they're just businesses
and they have a bottom line that's all
that really matters in the end for most
of them especially the big ones and then
Occupy Wall Street started I had been
active in the hacker community so this
is where the activist journalist thing
comes in when I started doing this I
didn't care for whatever journalism was
because journalism was corporate
narrative garbage they would ignore what
the truth was we'd have uh you know I'd
have friends who were involved in some
kind of worldly geopolitical action and
the media would just be completely wrong
about it I remember I had a friend who
competed in the X Games the next day in
the front page in the paper completely
wrong about what happened and I'm just
like I don't know whatever that is I'm
not involved with so me you know when I
went down to Occupy Wall Street it was
information activism is what we referred
to it as in the hacker community
collecting and disseminating information
and then I was like oh that's what
journalism was supposed to be you know
so so when you when you get those cross
narratives and then you get a a media
ecosystem that doesn't care for the
Nuance just writes a quick fires it off
you end up with
you know like on Wikipedia it says these
things and it doesn't really explain the
context of how these things end up
happening so you know after like six
months I have these uh journalists say
you realize journalism is literally just
collecting and disseminating information
and I was like oh well I grew up
watching a bunch of people lie on the TV
for special interest so that's what
journalism was to me yeah right and now
it's like oh okay I get that I get that
but with um increasing notoriety from
being acted by Wall Street being on the
ground in uh namely with Berkeley the
conflict between antifa and right-wing
groups I I started gaining too much
attention you know I went and went to
Sweden filmed like a two-week Vlog
covering escalation of crime and stuff
like that and then by the time I'm back
in the United States after a couple
years it's impossible for me to go out
and film anything anymore so this is
maybe like seven or eight years into my
specifically journalistic career I'm
having people run up to me in these
these these moments and instead of me
covering what's happening people are
running up to me and I can't do this
anymore you know they're running up to
you doing what exactly oh man I'm a big
fan it's a great orb right up to me and
swinging at me oh great because I'm like
okay one or the other yeah if I show up
here there's no more story I'm the story
and so I I can't do it and then that
slowly caused a transformation into
commentary podcast because this is what
I would do I would go down and I would
stream the Occupy Wall Street thing
specifically was a 21 hour straight live
broadcast
where the park got raided and I was
there 21 hours holding up my phone
people were bringing me batteries to get
my phone from shutting down and uh I'm
doing live commentary in real time as
all this stuff's happening to you know
millions of people how old are you at
the time oh man what was I 25 maybe oh
yeah this is 2009 2011 so yeah it was
25. and it's been questionable so you're
from Chicago your mom and dad like blue
collar your dad was a firefighter and
your mom sold cars yeah so I mean a lot
of things my dad uh was a firefighter he
was a former Marine he uh also did uh I
think General construction stuff on the
side obviously trying to detailed cars
whatever we could do uh to make ends
meet my mom sold cars but then
um around the time I was like nine my
mom put everything up to open a coffee
shop which lasted for about two years
before not making it due to a lot of
reasons namely the corporate Starbucks
walls came in there worse government
yeah they tore up all the streets on
their outside of Chicago right and so
there was no more foot traffic for a lot
of these businesses and revenue great
and then and then and Tim and you left
school at 14. yeah and then just yeah I
was going to high school for like two
months he was just like I can't I'm done
oh it's the stupidest waste of time wow
yeah you're not advocating not
graduating high school though absolutely
really a lot of time uh there's this
weird uh conflating of a high school
diploma with a path to success it makes
literally no sense locking
taking someone who's 14 and saying go
into an institutionalized learning
facility which will give give you no
real world life skills for four years
talk about wasting formative years what
I did I was programming websites I was
doing Flash animation I was making video
games I was playing music I was
traveling I was skateboarding traveling
around the the area of the city meeting
people and expanding my horizons while
my friends were locked in a box learning
for the fifth year
it's not like I I can't even tell you
they learned anything because the the
reason why I was like I'm done with this
I remember going to a high school math
class we'll call it teacher walks in she
goes uh to turn to page 17 and do those
problems and then walks out of the room
and then we're all sitting around like
what just happened
yes every single math class was that and
I'm like okay my favorite was um
sitting in a room in English class and
having someone go
the the teacher says all right everyone
turn to page 47 and we're going to read
the story from Mark Twain and I'm
sitting there and then uh Jeremy can you
read the and so inside
encyclopedia and today junior yeah and
so I'm just like bro I could read this
whole thing in 10 seconds what am I
doing here it says wasting my time so
I'll just stop I'm out were you living
with your parents at the time yes with
my mom my parents were split up
and then uh actually what happened was
I'm 14 and they did this weird thing
where they changed our schedule from in
grade school it was 7 30 a.m to 2 30 p.m
then they decided for freshman year at
the local high school we're going to do
10 45 a.m to like 5 30 p.m and a lot of
parents were upset they were like this
means that in Winter 14 year old kids
are going to be leaving High School in
the dark like that's crazy and so it was
it was like a a kind of a cultural shock
for me at 14 because you'd get out of
school at 2 30 you go to the park you'd
hang out with your friends you'd come
home it's 2 30 of the whole day ahead of
you school got it now it's like I wake
up at six in the morning because that's
what the schedule always had been my
entire life
and but now I said I'm sitting in my
living room with my hands on my knees
like
um daytime TV People's Court is on what
am I supposed to do with this get to
school at 10 45 get out at six and it's
time for dinner time for bed and so it
was ridiculously stressful and then
after two months of
insane nonsense not learning a damn
thing I'm 14 I'm halfway to school and I
just sit down in the grass I started
crying and then I got up and turned
around went home called my mom and said
I'm not going to school anymore what'd
you see she I think I can't really
remember I think she said okay
I went from being a straight A student
to a straight F student from grade
school to high school and so my parents
were already like something's not
happening what changed during that time
like did you have a life-changing event
a bad breakup were you smoking weed were
you hanging out with some crowd were you
reading a new book were you uh into
something or no no really no uh in my
life I've smoked wait a handful of times
it just doesn't do anything for me uh it
wasn't hanging out the bad crowd uh
playing music but I think the big issue
was
I I I'm since I was a little kid my
family's had computers I built my first
computer when I was probably seven or
eight years old it sounds impressive to
the average person but it's like I went
to a thrift store bought five pieces and
stuck them together like Legos it's not
the craziest thing in the world
installed Windows on it so my family's
got CompuServe we've got AOL I'm online
I'm reading about the president I'm
reading about I'm reading about the
world this is Clinton at this point or
bush this was I think I think this was
Bush yeah this is this is shortly after
9 11 I think yeah I think so I think I
was 14 it's shortly after so I'm reading
all this stuff online about what's going
on not a whole lot but I'm uh I was I
was Pro I was uh programming things in
Flash I was making websites I was
skateboarding in my life I'm doing all
these things that every day was
improving learning how to use Flash to
make a website and everyone's like wow
you made a website making an animation
where I mean the crude flash animations
like newgrounds.com stuff but every day
I could see something more I started
programming video game within you know
five days I've made a rudimentary video
game that's kind of like Mario Bros a
platformer where you play a little guy
running through a Factory and there's
little monsters and stuff these are
things that were tangible that I could
see were were being completed
then I go to school and they're tying my
hands together and saying sit down shut
up and do nothing and it was it's like
being locked in prison and So eventually
I was just like I'm not doing this it's
it's I'm done you have kids not no when
you have kids you're gonna send them to
high school
probably not no probably not I mean uh
I'm like I'm gonna homeschool I plan on
having kids uh but they're going to be
homeschooled
um probably some kind of local pod
learning thing you want kids to
socialize with each other but I think
kids should be learning from adults not
from kids and I think one of the biggest
things that we do today as a society is
we have children learn from each other
we separate kids from their parents like
cows and calves then we put the kids in
a box where they don't care for the
teacher and the teacher doesn't care for
them and then all of their social
interactions are predicated upon other
kids the behaviors of other kids when I
was growing up my family at a coffee
shop all of my social interactions are
with people in their 30s who are buying
coffee and complaining about Republicans
Or democrats yeah so here I am I'm 10
years old and I like all I want to do is
buy Pokemon when it comes out and I'm
trying to save it for the tip jar but
when I'm sitting there the conversation
isn't did you hear what Billy said about
you know Power Rangers it's did you see
what policy was passed I can't believe
they're doing this and that's the stuff
I'm absorbing the behaviors I'm learning
from are adults in in semi-professional
settings they're at the coffee shop
they're writing their work working or
they're playing music my mom's showing
me how to manage the business and the
finances then I go back to this this is
I'm like I'm like sixth or seventh grade
and all of the kids are imitating each
other so what's going to happen when
these kids grow up well I I'm not
surprised to find that
I'm running a business and most of my
friends are
just working regular jobs they've
they've not gone I'm not saying it's a
bad thing that everyone has to do it I'm
saying don't be surprised if
you take a kid you put them in an
environment where they learn how
businesses work and businesses run and
when they grow up they're doing those
things you plant the seeds those seeds
will grow
Pat your similar story right well not 14
but there's a part of what he's talking
about that you know he's got a very big
a good point I mean what we don't know
about is the following Tim Howard are
you 86 is what so you're 37 okay so we
don't know what it is to be 14 today now
think about it we don't know what it is
to be 14 today and how you're fed stuff
and you know how you view the world when
you're talking about you know you're
you're in high school and you're going
through it and you know we we were at
AOL chat like I'm thinking 1994 was AOL
chat if a guy was on if a friend of you
was on L chat hey meet me in this room
and you would go and I was like oh my
God turn on the old Chad you wait for a
couple minutes so things in journalism
is changing in in a very different way
think about today's Temple Tim at 14
years old today what is that kid doing
today what is he what route is he taking
what what's pissing him off what journey
is he going to be going through we're 20
years from now the next Temple you're
sitting and he's telling us about what
it's like to be 14 in 2023 and we have
to sit there and watch it I got an 11
year old nine-year-old six-year-old
and a almost two-year-old in a month and
I I talked to them and ask them so what
what do you learn in school about uh
politics what do you think about this
what do you think about that and with
Tico he can have a full-blown
conversation with you at 11. yeah he and
he wants to have that conversation Dylan
wants to talk Patrick Mahomes Zilla
wants to talk sports he's a sports guy
but it's going to be interesting to see
what happens next 20 years with this so
even with you like you know you you
interview a lot of people you're you're
in the streets they contact you I'm
assuming a lot of the 14 year olds and
15 year olds today that could be the
next temples probably look up to you
they see what you did maybe some of them
are watching the next citizen journalist
what do you think is going to happen
with the how citizen journalism is going
to evolve over the next 5 10 15 20 years
well so it depends on your definition of
citizen journalism the the original
definition was when an act of Journalism
was undertaken by a citizen so when they
started calling a citizen journalist it
was a an act of derision to separate me
from the corporate Press Citizen
journalism was a guy's walking his dog
down the street when he sees a burning
building he pulls out his phone he films
it and then uploads it to Twitter he
never thinks twice he goes because on
his on his day and and then CBS says can
we use this footage what they did was
they took a professional or independent
journalist like me and many others who
specifically bought equipment who make
money doing this who sell footage and
they said you're just a citizen
journalist that way when we would go to
events namely I'm speaking at event they
had guys actually stand up and question
that they had a panel of corporate
journalists saying citizen journalism is
not real journalism these people are not
trustworthy you shouldn't listen to them
it's just citizen journalism yeah it was
intended to diminish our work undermine
what you're doing now I would just call
it independent journalism Independent
Media and uh the corporate prices in
absolute Decay Vice I mean what happened
there what happened there oh boy unpack
that for us because you you were there
2014 you know this company goes from 5.7
billion uh Rob can you go to their
YouTube channel real quick and then go
to videos
go to Vice you know they got 16.8
million Subs yeah they got 16.8 million
Subs wow so okay go right there and then
go to videos go to the videos
go to popular I'll explain it go to
popular okay so now watch this zoom in a
little bit top the most viewed video
ever 84 million then 58 million 50
million 46 million keep going down 39
million 32 million 29 million 28 million
26 million I mean I can keep going on
and on and on and on these didn't these
guys do fire Festival the documentary
they had I think they had a list how
long ago did you see the one on the top
uh the world's greatest ass the
Brazilian one I've seen that a couple
times let me that actually inspired you
to want to go to Brazil well I've been
there twice you got to find that out let
me just let me just read these
documentaries and then I want you to
talk and tell us the story of advice so
top 10 documentaries the vice guide to
North Korea 2008 the vice guy to Congo
2011. the devil you know 2019 the vice
Guy 2 Karachi 2011. heavy metal in
Baghdad 2007 big night outs 2015.
teenage Exorcist 2013 inside the
Superhuman world of the Iceman 2015. uh
the true cost of climate denial 2016.
inside the Michigan militia 2016. I mean
they've done some work so what happened
with these guys to go from 5.7 to
another bankruptcy I'll give you a a mix
of conjecture statements from people I
know who work at the company and my
personal opinion the reason I think if
you look at their uh videos that have
the most views like the biggest ass in
Brazil from 11 years ago is their number
four uh a lot of these videos I think
it's because one I mean some of these
things are just over sex yeah like
that's kind of obvious the first four
yeah the top four and then even down
below yeah but uh here's what happens in
uh 10 or so years ago
YouTube was panicking because Netflix
was starting to steal its audience share
I actually had a meeting with Google and
they said to me Netflix is our biggest
competition and I said if that's if
that's how you view it you're in trouble
because that's not what people are doing
on YouTube
my my view was it YouTube is the place
where people go to see viral videos to
upload content and it's a social media
platform Netflix is a corporate Channel
if you want to be like them then you're
gonna lose all of this now YouTube's
doing fine right but what happens with
vice vice was producing these
documentaries and putting them up on
their website they did not have access
to the big corporate channels they were
Outsiders
well so what do they do they say well
we'll put them on YouTube YouTube's a
relatively new thing I'd only been for
like six years been up around for like
six or so years and it was a way to
upload for free so if you're running a
business and you you say I want to
upload this documentary Market our brand
and sell subscriptions or advertisements
I don't want to spend money doing it
YouTube covers the cost of that
YouTube started putting these Vice
documentaries on the front page
and this is this is my my personal
opinion having been my experience I'm
sure there's probably more Nuance to
what happened
with nothing on YouTube that Rivals
Netflix and YouTube desperate to compete
with Netflix they were looking for
anything that could be seen as long-form
content Vice puts up a documentary
YouTube says put that on the front page
we need to compete with Netflix instant
50 million views that does not mean
people actually were seeking out Vice
and saying this is the best content of
the world it was this is what was placed
in front of me I watched it it was
pretty good you ended up with a bunch of
pretty cool things like I always
reference the Scopolamine I love that
that's one of my favorite ones it's
scary as hell but think about what it is
it's called the devil's breath uh
world's scariest drug go down a little
bit Rob on the left the guy's holding
those things it's from Colombia there's
a leaf that Pat you blowing in
somebody's face and they lose all uh
self-control and they don't remember
nothing like that that's they're saying
like the government uses it to make
people do crazy [__] it's that's one of
the best documentaries I've seen in a
long time but but their their
documentaries it was a good show yes the
original Vice show which then got bought
by HBO it meant it's a whole very
interesting story I think CBS wanted to
buy it and this again a lot of
conjecture from the people inside Vice
who I knew who are high level my
understanding was that
they had this hit on YouTube
partially I think largely because
YouTube was recommending it because they
needed long they needed long form
premium content makes sense the
Brilliance of Shane Smith the
businessman is once he got those hits he
says this opens the door to everything
else they started shopping around the
show saying look how many people watch
our Show online that could be yours
I think CBS I think it was CBS I could
be wrong it's been a decade wanted it
they said no swearing or something like
that and uh Vinnie you're not gonna make
it um I'm done but this is this is
Network TV and so their attitude was
like we can't be Vice if we're
constrained and trying to be clean cut
HBO said you can do whatever you want
yeah however I don't think HBO wanted to
renew the show after the first year and
the story I was told again I'm being
very careful here was that uh Shane the
CEO just announced they got renewed
anyway to create public pressure to
force HBO to renew them because they had
announced all the renewals for next
season Vice was not one of them and then
all of a sudden the CEO comes out and
says we've been renewed for two more
seasons I don't know if that's true or
not it's just rumors from inside the
office maybe it's not true it seems like
a crazy story and but but I I was
explicitly told part of that renewal was
the show is no longer the Wild
Adventures of ice it is going to be a
news magazine with a with with diversity
so we no longer want to see four white
men we want to see women people of color
and so uh explicitly for me I was told
that that removed me from the running
from being involved in that when they
hired me because I'm too much of a white
guy you should have just identified as a
black woman but you've got your job I'm
Korean and Japanese doesn't matter they
don't care they don't care they say it
they they Vice never said this to me
explicitly other than they want us to
have more women and and people of color
and then I'm just like hey how about
this my mom's Korean they're like I'm
sorry there's nothing we can do not
create enough buddy you're not I mean
you have to look very very discernably
to the the white Executives like you're
not whites now I'll tell you this as an
aside when I worked for Fusion they
explicitly told me you cannot be part of
what we do because you are because you
look too white have a nice day it's
racist nothing you can do about it but
uh they straight up told you that like
yeah this is Fusion you're a great guy
you bring amazing information too white
for us though yeah yeah yeah so Tim
here's my here's my question so you work
for Fusion you work for vice basically
they're telling you to lie and push
their agenda what's the what was their
advice was awesome Vice was dope so
Fusion was a whole different Fusion
started out awesome and then shifted
yeah yeah so so was there was there a
moment and was there a defining moment
or was it a gradual thing that made you
completely shift and become the temple
we see today I mean I I I I think I've
very much always been
kind of who I am my dad was more
concerned with my mom was more liberal
so we're but we're very much like Urban
liberal Chicago family uh the reason why
I wanted to work for vice I don't care
for Democrats or Republicans never did I
you know I voted for Obama felt totally
betrayed when he started bombing these
Villages I'm just like it's just more
War I don't I saw Shane Smith the CEO on
I think uh Colbert Report and he said
look we're not Democrats we're not
Republicans we're just storytellers
we're trying to go see these things and
I was like that's cool then I'm watching
these videos on YouTube I'm like that's
cool I want to do that so when I'm on
the ground doing this live stream stuff
I'm seeing this I'm like this is clearly
valuable it's getting a lot of traffic I
don't have the best way to monetize it
so I went to a couple different
companies one of one was vice and I
pitched this idea Vice after eight
months or so agreed and said okay we're
gonna bring you on and have you do the
stuff here in exchange for the live
stream reporting we will do hosted
documentaries with you and I said that's
great we did a bunch of really big ones
I went to Ukraine interviewed I I the
one I'm most proud of is I was the field
producer for the North Korean Motorcycle
Diaries which has you know five million
I went and interviewed kim.com which was
big for them five million or whatever so
that worked for me and I was excited for
it but just to go back to the uh what
what changed at these companies when I
was at Vice they never told me
you have to say this you can't say that
and with the uh the kim.com The Man
Behind mega upload which is what eight
million views they were sitting on it
and I went to them and said breaking
news is happening they've they're
they're you know that's why when it
starts it says before the release of
this you know this thing happened and
then they were like okay we'll add that
to the dock and then we'll put it out
like there was there was there was no
beef it was literally hey guys we have
to do this because of this reason
they're like we hear you loud and clear
Tim like let's do it
the the main issue was as they launched
Vice news things started to become more
isolated more spread out less when I
first started it was basically I'd walk
up to the executives walking around
what's up guys fist bump you know and
then within a year it was they're too
busy they got money from Murdoch there's
a massive expansion happening
you're going to be now dealing with this
guy
and so my attitude very much was that
is beneath me having me who's bringing
who came to you negotiating specifically
a new methodology and technology for
reporting now report to a guy who has no
idea what's going on has created clutter
and confusion and resulted in chaos
who's that guy I'm not gonna say his
name okay but he's a guy that replaced
Shane or he's no no no no he was a guy
who was uh
promoted within the company yeah yeah
and so I said you're going to run this
thing and so uh was he a guy that had
credibility amongst others in the
company or not yeah yeah I mean except
for the fact I think he got fired for uh
sexually assaulting or something like
that I don't know but that that's
another reason why Vice went woke so
people are advised they know who you're
talking about the people who are
listening to this absolutely okay they
don't know what you're talking about
okay so he comes in you're like this
guy's beneath me so that was kind of
like he didn't know what he was doing
and uh uh to find that Define what it
means he doesn't know what he's doing he
didn't know how social media worked he
didn't know how scheduling videos worked
he didn't know when people watched
videos he he had a bunch of ridiculous
ideas and he was allowed to do them
because he was friends with the boss and
that put me in a position where I'm like
quite literally the world where I grew
up and the things that I've built are
now I now have a roadblock between me
and the mission because
this guy was threatening to quit this is
what I was told he was running to quit
so then they said well we'll promote you
so then I go to the CEO and I said yeah
and I said here's what I want here's
what I need and here's what I can give
you in exchange he says agreed I had
three of these meetings I would come
back and I'd say when I came here I said
I want accent exchange for why I am not
getting what I asked for and he says I'm
sorry we'll take care of you handshake
Shane's a great guy and uh the problem
is
you know what what is it called the
Peter Principle or whatever you you
start putting less competent people as
they get promoted through the company to
the point of incompetence and so I
remember one day I go to Shane and I'm
and and he's he's pissed off he's
dealing with a bunch of bunch of uh
stuff and I said I said I need these two
guys hired if we're going to do what you
want me to do these two guys are the
only guys I know who have this expertise
in Mobile live stream news reporting
field reporting and he goes okay looks
at this dude and says hire them okay
done bye we leave the room the moment
walk up the door this guy turns me
because I'm not hiring anybody and I was
like this guy's a huge waste of my time
so I remember it was it was particularly
satisfactory when I quit that company
because that's just I I guess that's
part of what happens you know you you
start expanding it becomes more and more
corporate then the CEO says get
something done and the guy says no well
you know you kept them around that's
your problem and the guy ultimately got
fired I think I think he got fired
because he was uh sexually harassing him
but everybody knew he was I mean but it
was legitimate I mean the stories I
heard before it even happened it was
like I don't think anybody liked that
guy let me ask you based on this story
this seems to be a perfect case example
from uh barbarians to bureaucrats no
like the bureaucrat was put in he's a
flag carrier Shane Smith CEO how much uh
truth is that right well you have to
realize the the media by the way Shane
at the peak was worth 1.6 billion when
the company was worth 5.7 billion in
2017 he owned 28 percent of shares I
think is that 50 million dollars today
but he was 1.6 billion at one point uh
and Disney used to put 100 million
dollars hundreds of millions of dollars
into Vice at one point and Disney was
going to buy Vice if I'm not mistaken at
three billion dollars in 2015 give or
take again these numbers can be verified
on what I'm saying here's the part on
the on the creative side
like if you look at all the case studies
of different media companies out there
right you have to look at them closely
so there is operators there's creatives
okay the the creatives that have to
operate and grow the company there are
very few of those guys like musk is a
creative and he can operate and grow a
company right let's let's face okay look
at Shapiro what a smart thing he did so
he's a talent he's a brain he's not
duplicatable this is a guy that was
going to be the you know grew up wanting
to be the Supreme Court you know so he
says listen hey uh uh uh
look you operate you're also creative
but you're an operator you run National
I want to be over here in you know
Florida and I'm going to be creative and
we're going to make this work and grow
the company and then there's the money
guys that are from the Texas people so
when a creative gets to a point that he
no longer knows how to operate you have
to step aside and bring somebody that's
fully qualified to operate who can earn
the respect of the talent that knows
what they're doing if you bring somebody
that doesn't earn the respect effect of
a talent that's doing the work that
doesn't know the basic day-to-day stuff
you know how annoying it is to work in a
report to somebody like that of course
it's the most annoying I don't know the
story so all I'm doing is I'm trusting
what you're telling me so I'm not in the
inside I don't have friends advice but
I've heard a lot of good things about
this guy I've heard this guy was a guy
that people actually liked working for I
don't know the whole story him and I've
never had a conversation together before
but uh to go from that size to now where
it is today so uh uh uh another question
for you with profile of a vice
so you know when you work at ESPN they
have a certain profile on who they
recruit that does well at ESPN they all
stand up tall they all got their
shoulders perfect stand up they're six
feet tall and you so hey so today we're
going to look at the highlights of the
Lakers look what happened LeBron James
and Antonio they got a certainly you
know think that they're looking for
profile who they recruit Colombia
University you know where you come from
boom you fit perfect in here profile for
Fox profile for this profile for that
what was the ideal profile of people
they brought into Vice was it Rebels was
it you know how CIA sometimes you know
we got friends in the CI we've had a lot
of them on the show here who do they
hire preferably somebody that doesn't
have maybe got some ties with parents
you don't have anybody you really living
for there's a part of you that's willing
to risk it all you're not that tied to
anything that emotion somebody can
there's there's these profiles you look
at right what was the ideal profile of
somebody they brought advice at their
Peak at their Peak I was only there for
I was like there for about a year and a
half I don't want to you know that 20
years before I was there but I think if
you look at me the the obvious answer is
hipster-ish Post Punk was there a lot of
guys like you in there
I mean I mean what do you mean by guys
like me hipster punk you know like you
know because I'm like a weird weird guy
but I would say uh um confident
capable Outsiders
confident capable Outsiders that's what
I'm looking yeah so so it's it's it's
tough to describe I mean they have
hipster-ish kind of people they had
roguish people around the time I was I
was uh I joined and this is obviously
how it was going they took the 70
million dollars from from Murdoch I
think it was a News Corp or something
and then started firing the ogs and
bringing in LinkedIn professionals and
that really changed a lot you know they
had uh without getting too specific
because I want to keep people to their
private give people their privacy but
you know there's like one guy who
clearly would not be in a New York Media
Company handling this part of the
company and with the company for a
really long time
70 million bucks come in they ask them
in two seconds and then go on LinkedIn
and then find some professional from a
from a corporate you know News Channel
and now she's running the show you know
does that affect culture within the
company
yep and I think yeah I wonder
um for one I think Shane Smith is a
really good guy uh anybody who actually
was was good at their job and uh was
capable had no issues with him it was
the people who were lazy and incompetent
that would complain it's like dude
that's anybody complaining about their
boss but I've heard nothing but good
things about him and he took care of the
people around him uh to a great degree
but as he starts rising up and the
company's expanding a separation starts
to begin between the leader who has
built the confidence of his people and
now these subordinates who generate no
confidence at all so I don't know what
was your question again
I was more looking at the profile part
so you said confident capable well like
young outside girl you know what I mean
yeah are you are you are you charismatic
young and and were a lot of people like
you who came knocking on the door saying
I'd like to be advice or did they go
looking oh that was it so it was more
people wanting to be part of us yeah
Shane Shane I think publicly stated it
was a cult
most big companies are though I mean
Apple wasn't called most of these
companies that make it to that size they
have that kind of a feeling I think he
said something like when people started
begging him to work for him saying they
would work for him for free he realized
he had something and they there was a
Supreme Court case around interns that
made them get rid of a whole bunch of
the unpaid labor that they did have but
when I quit
every single person in media was shocked
like that I knew I'm not saying like
literally everybody media was talking
about I'm saying like the people I knew
agents networks my friends why would you
quit Vice
wow are you crazy this is the company
and I was just thinking like
now look where they are now you know
what I mean I I don't think Shane's
unhappy he's still worth 50 80 million
dollars or more he cashed out 30 million
dollars he's he he's he's got more money
he can ever spend and he said that but
uh did you see the writing on the wall
ahead of time it wasn't just the
bureaucrat that you were doing at the
corporate level at what level what I'm
sorry at what time frame like at what
point did you know the writing was on
the wall I mean
the changes that were happening
implied chaos
right we built this office then a week
you know a few several months later well
it was a different office now we're
going to move this off this year now
we're gonna move it back and I'm like
they're spending tens of millions of
dollars on a 30 million dollar in New
York then they they bought another
portion of the building then they're
planning on moving I'm like
it doesn't seem like there's a long-term
plan here and the other issue was
one of the things that Shane's really
really good at I remember talking to a
friend after I left
they have What's called the State of the
Union at the company
and this is a story as it was told to me
it could be wrong he comes out and he
says uh ladies and gentlemen we got our
cable channel and everyone ah and
they're all screaming and cheering
there's Pizza beer and ice cream and so
my friend uh is talking to me
and uh he says I'm gonna be running news
production for the cable cable channel
and I went wow so what are you moving to
Toronto no what do you mean I thought
you were gonna work on the cable channel
he's like I am and I'm like oh okay so
are you going to be living in Toronto
and he goes bro why would I be living in
Toronto I was like it's a Rogers Telecom
deal it's a Canadian cable channel yeah
and he was like huh you see what Shane
was really good at was assumptive
language he said we got our cable
channel creating the idea in the minds
of the employees that Vice was the
biggest and the best and they're going
to be on American terrestrial you know
cable networks at the time no it was
Canada it was 30 million you know people
at Max and 20 million households but the
employees that I knew
well they made the mistake of assuming
they were going to be American cable
television so he was really good at
rallying and boosting morale and making
people think they were on the mothership
of the greatest media Empire on the
planet when in reality it was like you
know a nice sized yacht but you're not
the 100 million dollar yacht out there
with Bezos on it you're the you know 15
30 million dollar yacht that can carry
20 people what was he doing before Vice
Shane
I don't know I was only there for you I
don't know but but I know that if you if
you pull up the article I just sent you
I just sent you an article from
yesterday Wall Street Journal I don't
know if you saw this you've probably
seen this uh Vice media nears a deal for
400 million dollars sale go down a
little bit out of a bankruptcy no no let
me just read at the top I'm sorry I was
just saying to be able to read the tap
yeah the media businesses talks to sell
itself to top lenders Fortress
investment and Soros fund man
isn't that weird reorganization would
wipe out other investors Now look up 250
million debt financing Soros Vice stay
on that real quick and then go back go
go to the 250 million dollars let me
just read the bottom and then go to that
go up a little bit I just want to see
what else is yeah right there right
there there's a fortress 400 million
dollars nearly every Vice stock quote
holding cooling backers such as private
Equity from tpg63 and Mogul gens would
be wiped out under the proposed
organization wow people familiar with
the matter outstanding debts held by
tpg63 would be impaired as part of the
plan that people said the Murdoch family
is a major shareholder in the journal
parent News Corp the plant cell of the
company of its lenders would value if I
said around 400 million dollar including
debt the people set a steep drop from
5.7 million okay now go to the 250
million dollars
Vice media gets 250 million dollar debt
funding from
George 2018. and so this is debt funding
so what they're saying now is that 400
million evaluation includes the debt he
already had so what does that mean not
to mention earlier this I think it was
earlier this year they got 30 million
dollars in debt financing I imagine it
might have been from Soros so we're
talking about they're sitting on 280
million dollars in debt is that 400 but
is that 400 million evaluation mean that
Soros fund is buying the company for 120
million
right right because he's not going to
pay his own debt back assuming the debt
and right
or however much they may have paid back
so so people point out the Soros thing
and I'm like yeah that was that was four
years ago
but you know my view of it was there was
a uh there was an article that was out
uh came out a long time ago and it was a
little cartoon animation they made of
Shane Smith with a frying pan and a book
in it and he was flipping it because
they said that he was cooking the books
and uh what they accuse him of doing I
don't know if it's true okay I'm just
saying this is this is a big narrative
that um he would do this very clever
thing where he would say this year we
put a million we put a billion dollars
on the books
what does that really mean well to the
average person who doesn't know much
about the industry or business or
Finance or Deals they think he added a
billion dollars in Revenue what he's
actually saying is we did a 10 10 year
we did a 30-year deal I love this one we
did a I just I just uh gave a guy uh
this is what the casino does near me
they say you could win one million
dollars if you enter this raffle in the
bottom and fine print it says 25 000 a
year for 40 years oh great great so
they're going to give you two grand per
month for 40 years maybe the average age
of the person at the casino is not going
to live for four years but they call it
giving you a million bucks very very
clever financing this is marketing but
that's an annuity though most life
insurance
Lottery uh winners get an annuity the
point is though when you you are told
enter this contest for a chance to win a
million dollars and what they're
actually saying is 25k a year it's a
very very different you think you get a
million dollars what I'm saying to you
is what they're telling you is we're
giving you million dollar annuity that's
that's what they're saying an annuity is
you know when you win the lottery if you
win 100 million dollars if you take the
whole thing up front you're going to get
taxed what 50 percent yeah you're gonna
get 40 you're gonna get 40. you're gonna
end up getting 50 million bucks let's
just say 40 million bucks versus you
take an annuity and you say I want to
take this 100 million dollars over a
40-year period okay then you're gonna
get two and a half million bucks every
year for 40 years right that's an option
and you pay less tax the point is
if I walked up to the average person and
said if you buy a raffle ticket from me
you could win one million dollars
they're not expecting to get two
thousand dollars per month for 40 years
they think my life will change I'll buy
a house I get that so I just I just
think that part you know there's a lot
of things I don't again I don't know
these guys I don't know what they're
doing I mean my concern is a whole
different concern my concern is if you
go to an investor yeah and say we need a
hundred million dollars to expand and we
just put 300 million on the books this
year yeah
what do you think that investor is
thinking I mean look at any Savvy
investor is going to be like what does
that mean on the books this year but
there's a clever thing that was being
done in media in the 2010s well it was
called um ad rights assignments or ad
right sales all of these media companies
would take their gold standard brand
they'd pay for Let's uh let's let's call
it splice just a random word related to
an unrelated company and uh they would
say get uh 30 million views per month
they would then go to another website
that generate a click form you ever see
those articles where it's like you won't
believe where the celebrity is now yeah
and it's like 25 photos you click it and
then there's 800 ads and one picture of
Tom Cruise you click next it loads a new
page that's click farming that is the
worst and then you're not now you're
seven pages in you're like I gotta go
what the hell where the hell is Tom
Cruise where's Tom Cruise here's how it
works and it probably still happens
today
splice would go to that company and say
sell us the rights to sell ads on your
views and they would say you got it
splice would then say the 50 million
garbage views from that trash website
are now a part of splice views they
would then go to advertise and say the
splice Network gets 80 million views per
month don't you want to be a part of it
the advertiser thinks they're buying the
gold standard of content what they don't
realize is their ads are being assigned
to a garbage clickbait website no one
actually reads your beef is it sounds
like it at least on the surface sort of
a bait and switch type of deal but
here's I think it's fraud but here's
what I love about about you know what
you're saying and a lot of people do
that they all did it too yeah he's
absolutely and by the way there's
another magazine that we were trying to
buy six months ago Tom and Mario know
about this one here we're on a call with
them and remember back in the days when
people would buy fake YouTube views and
you know it would show 17 million views
17 comments I said dude you did not get
70 million and you could buy these views
I'm like well I'm gonna go buy views I'm
gonna go buy views and then Twitter you
can buy a million followers for five
thousand dollars and you're getting two
retweets or one retweet right he knows
this this was running even when uh I
don't know what Gingrich or they did
Obama thing on his uh followers 75
percent of followers on Twitter was fake
or whatever the number was this was on
one of the elections that took place but
here's the thing if you do that
say you sell advertisers there's this
magazine that sold this show to a big
phone company okay and I'm listening to
the pitch and they said we got 28
million views it's the number one show
it's competing with Shark Tank I'm
watching the show because I was invited
to be one of the hosts on the show I'm
like guys I know YouTube You Know
YouTube this is how you're selling it to
this phone company yeah
you're not getting these views as a
YouTuber I know show me your AdSense on
the back and how many if you're saying
this thing got 70 million views how much
money did you make on this how many
advice how did you get 17 million views
but only 28 cents on revenue on this
video the point becomes that strategy
that a lot of guys did in 2010s and he's
right a lot did it they did it on
YouTube they did it on Twitter today you
know what the advertisers are finally
listening they're learning okay we'll
test you out for one ad two ads three
ads dude we got no conversion we're not
coming back and then if you have a
reputation of people dropping you over
and over and over again
all they're gonna say is yeah these ads
don't convert because you have just as
much of a job if you bring in a sponsor
to convert theirs he knows this as they
do they may give you 100 Grand or 200
Grand or half a million dollars but
they're expecting is this going to
convert or not but what if then you uh
get those 70 million views or whatever
disable comments and just and then you
go to a network and say our show of 10
episodes got 7 million views each uh we
don't like the comments because people
have hate speech but if the advertisers
want to do that the advertisers the
network buys the show from you I get no
no well then the network who buys the
show uh have to go in the category of
qualified morons and that's totally fine
and that's going to happen as well
there's a lot of them out there yep a
lot it happened a lot well you're right
it happened a lot and a lot of people
got money and you know let's not forget
what YouTube did just two and a half
years ago three years ago and they said
you can no longer put the you know
thumbs down or when Biden was speaking
the thumbs down was gone you couldn't
see comments with disabled and nobody
wanted to even today when they go on
C-Span or some of these different places
comments are disabled you can't see an
Odessa that's a different story that's
because a lot and yesterday is something
was posted on now uh can you go to
Biden's Instagram I think it was Biden's
Instagram Tim I don't know if you saw
this or not they posted uh Joe Biden um
on his Instagram about uh job creation I
don't know if it's uh let me see if it's
that or if it's white house if I find
this I show it to you it showed as Joe
Biden being the greatest job Creator
ever in the history of America with
presidents and then all you have to do
is go in the comments section uh that's
all you have to do if you go in the car
there it is I see it you found it no not
that one it's this one here I'm going to
send it to you all you have to do is go
in the comments section oh there it is
uh no go to not that one go to uh the
Instagram one that I'm on is po2u POTUS
not uh Joe Biden go to POTUS
POTUS Instagram watch this the comments
are the best it's the best so go right
on the middle one right there so you see
this look what it shows jobs created by
President per month to go to Joe Biden
look at that Trump terrible Obama Bush
Clinton doesn't tell the whole story
that covet happened the last you know
year of trump and then read the comments
zoom in on the comments zoom in on the
comments okay zoom in go up after him
these are not Cherry Picked they're just
okay they'll come so trust me bro let's
first put it let's first read what the
POTUS said this is what happens when you
invest in America we have more work to
do but this is real progress Source
trust me bro now show me a line graph of
total jobs though yeah employment rate
before pandemic 61.5 now six and a half
you're not creating anything Society
just covering it up I would love for you
to define the world create award Creator
be be created and restored are two
different things by the way if I tell
you 99 of the comments there's a guy
that says Trust me I'm a Democrat and
you're lying yeah he says go look at my
profile on my Instagram I hate Trump I
hate the sentence but this is a lie
right yeah so
advertisers that one right there bro
this isn't even accurate I'm not a
republican
but by the way there's 50 these in there
that's not just one of them chart is a
bit misleading you're gonna spend 30
minutes going through all of it the
point the great thing about what's going
on today is the following here's a great
thing uh uh remember that one song It's
Friday Friday
yeah I'm like why am I even listening to
this song that's what's driving me
insane I'm listening this Friday it's
Friday and and then you're like dude
look at the comments it was like the
worst dislike you know thumbs down uh
video ever on YouTube she broke the
record and they interviewed her you know
165 million views how many is he's not
gonna show the thumbs down that's what I
want to see you can pause it because we
don't want her to say yeah I now get the
rights for this video but but the point
I'm trying to make is the great thing
about what direction we're going God
willing if we go this direction the fact
that Instagram allows for comments till
today and doesn't allow them to and and
they don't even do it yet because you
could do it on Instagram if they wanted
to block it YouTube would block the
comment section ads that they were
manipulating making money in 2010 yeah
now you can't do it and get away with it
all of this stuff is getting in the
direction of transparency hopefully if
they can pull this off that's when you
realize who's doing it right and who's
not doing it right yeah but but do you
think it's like because mind you there
there's a huge majority that believe
everything that this guy is saying
whatever this Administration is saying
he's the front runner and all that all
the lying like if you watch the White
House briefings Tim uh Korean
Jean-Pierre she's just blatantly lying
every single day about the board and
everything and not one not one only what
Peter Ducey once well nobody ever goes
excuse me you're full of [__] nobody's
doing it why she said the other day the
responsible thing the president had to
do it was not fair to have the kids stay
home you know the president make the
right decision to let them back to
school because it was hard on you know
what what are you talking about lady
right with all this stuff no the point
all the stuff I'm talking about yeah and
he's talking about Vice and Soros yeah
my biggest concern isn't uh some of
these things that's going on my biggest
concern is who's picking up all these
media companies no one on the right one
and picked up Vice who picks it up so
Rose and then the more and more and more
these guys pick it up and now Fox loses
Tucker fires him for whatever reason the
sun all the by the way what is your
interpretation of what's going on there
with Fox and Tucker I mean I don't know
just just from what I've seen of the
reports uh there's a couple different
theories Rupert Murdoch was threatened
personally by Tucker because his fiance
was saying he was a prophet and then the
wedding broke off and then Tucker gets
fired there's uh the fiance said Tucker
is a prophet that was one of the news
reports that came out that apparently
they had a dinner then Rupert Murdoch's
you know fiance saying like oh he's a
he's a prophet he's a genius oh God then
a month later he's like yeah I'm the
prophet yeah I I think from a business
perspective if you own a brand and then
you hire a personality and the
personality is becoming bigger than the
brand any CEO is going to get rid of
that that person's a threat to their
brand that's that's it you think so
I don't know any
Murdoch my view would be that Murdock is
saying Fox News is the company if we're
at a point where people are saying Fox
News is doomed because of one man that
man should not be at this company even
if it means it hurts us in the short
term in the long term Fox News needs to
stand on its own
yeah you you have a point there and the
reason why I say I don't think any
because I think Kraft Robert Kraft of
the New England Patriots
for every you know one person that knows
Robert Kraft a thousand people know Tom
Brady and and he was very comfortable
with Tom being day uh the show or
Belichick he kept those guys and Jerry
bus if you think about Jerry Buss Jerry
Buss was a Playboy you know but you know
in La he was always at the clubs with
the girls and all this stuff he was the
guy who wanted to party with he was a
big real estate guy in 33 years of
owning the Lakers they won 10
championships and he had the magic
bigger than Jerry butts Kobe bigger than
Jerry but Shaq bigger than Jerry Buzz
Pat Riley bigger than Jerry Buzz I think
there are some that can do it obviously
at this phase I don't know the internal
side of the story here but to have a
girl that you're dating
four or two
but is it messenger from God you know
what Rupert said I am God yeah if he's a
messenger I am God right anyways so you
know we're gonna see what's gonna happen
there with uh but some of these
Republicans or conservative as much as
they [__] about what's going on and
look what Soros is doing do you see how
dark Soros is look at all these media
stop I had to buy him or be quiet and
stop bitching about it he's gonna keep
buying them up you have money as well so
you're just using the money to buy real
estate and other [__] you can also
pick up some media to control your own
narrative and competing and you all you
do is 24 7. you have a look what Soros
is doing look what this guy's doing
we're putting our money on the line some
companies are putting their monies
online saying let's go play ball other
companies are sitting there saying look
how dark he is put up some money you
have money you know what must did musk
took 44 billion and bought Twitter at
the worst possible time at the worst
possible time and what did he call it
I'm running a freaking number profit
organization right so these are the kind
and by the way think about at the time
who's Elon Musk dated by the way Loki
who's elamas dated oh my God I mean he's
dated aliens he's dated everybody well
he is ones um but but the point is look
at musk's life yeah okay this guy's got
an incredible life and he chooses to go
by Twitter thank God and then it hurts
Tesla stock it hurts this it hurts that
and he doesn't give a [__] because he's
actually a freedom fighter if you look
at him now you know so some of these
other guys maybe if you're you know you
think you think some other guys are
going to get involved and want to
replicate what he's doing like you know
how Bezos was being a little bit vocal
towards biting like seven months ago I
don't know if you caught that or not and
you think more guys are going to say
listen guys if you're gonna do something
about it let's go play ball and put up
the money or just be quiet and stop
bitching about it there's there's I talk
about this quite a bit there's a lot of
people who will act like culture
Warriors concerned about free speech and
government who are very very wealthy and
then don't do anything
there are some people who do literally
everything uh Vivek ramaswamy I think
his net worth is around half a billion
or whatever he not not only starts a a
venture capital firm to compete with ESG
to oppose it he's trying to run for
president I'm like the this guy's
outright like I'm gonna put like Elon
Musk we're gonna throw it off respect to
him and he's a fighter I love it I vote
for him I vote for him 100 little joke
like he is a better version of Andrew
Yang okay yeah he's on steroids he's on
stairs he's injury hanging on steroids
yeah like you know how Andrew Yang I'm
an entrepreneur like how big was your
business have you had an exit but I'm an
entrepreneur we're like okay cool that's
great this guy's made money how did you
make your money what did you do all this
stuff we've actually no I build a
multi-billion dollar you know bio da da
da and here's where I'm at right now and
he writes the books and he goes out
there and by the way
do you see how fast his Twitter and his
audience is growing do you see how many
people are looking at this guy saying
damn this guy is great at explaining it
you know he's great at breaking things
down he's he's one of the guys that
during this season every time there's a
run a new Star is Born I think this guy
is a star being born just a few months
ago he had 40 000 followers on Twitter
you know you know the story is he's
working at he's building this
multi-billion dollar bio uh biotech
company the BLM riots happen
they come to him and say hey you should
put out a statement or you know change
your profile picture or whatever and
he's like oh okay yeah for sure because
he's like whatever and he puts out the
statement where he it's very neutral uh
we should come together and you know put
an end to the violence and we're all
Americans here apparently they came to
him and said that was inadequate it was
it was it was bad and then within a
month he had board members resign I'm
probably ruining the story to a certain
degree he told me the story and so I'm a
man here's my vision of Vivek ramaswamy
he's just he's an entrepreneur he just
want to start a business he wants to
create something of benefit he wants to
help Mankind and then he starts getting
beaten over the head by this woke ESG
corporate garbage that costs his
business money and friends and he didn't
even do anything he actually agreed with
them but not enough I think what they
did was they went to a guy of tremendous
intellect means and capability insulted
him and spat in his face and then he
just wiped it off and said you've
declared war I love what he's doing by
the way you know whether he does
anything in this one or not I hope he
doesn't go away me too uh he he is the
kind of guy that the opposition doesn't
want to debate because he's super
brilliant sharp history and made money
and as an entrepreneur and he's got a
background immigrant family story all of
that the profile is a is an anomaly okay
and he knows how to deliver the message
properly hopefully he gets more
attention and and not just that
he's uh I had him on my show called the
culture War podcast which is a new
Friday show I'm doing and he's sitting
there and he goes you know what I
probably shouldn't say this I'm gonna
get in trouble there's got to be some
Civic requirement for voting and he
talks about various ideas
um one of the ideas that we like to talk
about is service guaranteed citizenship
it's an idea that is a reference to
Starship Troopers in this story if you
want to vote you have to give two years
of service to the community in some
fashion either it's it's not necessarily
the military service it could be you
know working in a library or something
don't get Pat started on who he thinks
should vote but so uh one of the ideas
that Vivek brings up is uh maybe when
you when when you fill out your
Selective Service card you get a voter
ID and that is the bare minimum
requirement you you fill this out you
don't have to fill it out you could you
could say you know what I'm not going to
sign up for Selective Service and men or
women are both required to but when you
do now you can vote there's got to be
some standard I'm like that's a
particularly Brave thing to say yeah if
you genuinely believe yeah I think when
he was talking to me in an open format
just what do you want to do why want to
do it it felt real it felt genuine I
could feel the emotion of I'm like they
they they figuratively spat on this guy
who who and now he said then I I will
return fire I will go to war with you
and he's speaking about what he
genuinely thinks and believes
I told him this I said look I don't
think you're gonna win yeah but I do
think you're going to make the
conversation better and I do think
you're going to positively uh change
this country by standing up on a debate
stage saying everything you just said
and making DeSantis or Trump answer to
it do you think it's so funny you're
saying I was just going to say that I
think he'll make it on the stage
let's get into that part but it's funny
you're saying this I did this video in
2014 April 15 2014. Rob if you can pull
it up on uh YouTube to show it to him
and I broke it down
and so many people were pissed about
this video was a video titled earn the
right to vote okay uh earned the right
to vote and everything was about you I
don't care if you're 40 years old 20
years old or 14 years old I think a guy
that's 14 years old that's paying tax we
don't need to play the video I'm not
going to do this here nice Jersey I
don't care if you're 14 years old and
you're
paying taxes you have more right to vote
than a 26 year old staying at home who's
never paid taxes you can't vote so
became you have to pay a minimum of
amount of taxes to have the right to
vote I like that you know and then if
you did a few things your vote is
actually two votes wow if you serve the
military you get an additional vote if
you do this so the more you contribute
to society I love that the more of a
voice you have the less you contribute
to society the more matter of fact if we
ever ran a country you know what our tax
system would be it'd be Progressive
except the other way around oh really
you know what that means you know what
it means Progressive the other way
around here
the more you contribute the less you pay
because I'm thankful for you we're
thankful for you but the less you use
your talents to contribute to society
the more taxes you pay so the people
that don't use their god-given talents
get taxed at the highest level the
people that contribute their god-given
talents and go above and beyond you get
taxed the least because you're making
our life easier because you're creating
jobs for everybody so vivex thinking if
that's what you said he was telling you
about voting you know all that stuff
he's going to piss a lot of people off I
love it but I love it I keep lighting it
up but that's what I respect I'm like
for a politician or someone who's
running to come out and be like there's
got to be some kind of Civic requirement
that shows a lot of honesty oh Rob put
the link to this below if people want to
see it they can go back they're going to
disagree with a lot of things I talk
about but anyways you were going to ask
a question saying do you think he's
going to make it on the debate section
let's talk about that because I'll read
an article and then I'll uh
uh give it to you Tim so uh uh uh Wall
Street Journal story comes out about
Trump being afraid to debate okay of
course Trump is afraid to debate this is
Wall Street Journal May 4th just just a
couple days ago
uh and
it says reports suggest that Trump will
skip the first few Republican primary
debates because he is leading his
competitors are trailing and he is
scared of being up there on the stage
for two hours in an uncontrolled
environment with a group of people who
are grown uh gunning for him while Trump
supporters think in terms of wrestling
and believes that attacking Trump will
hurt their chances the presidency
requires a fight and Trump should be
challenged like any other candidate
Republicans who are soft Trump
supporters need to begin to see that the
American people won't let that man back
in the white house because of the
fraudulent attempts to subvert the
election culminating in the violent uh
overrunning of the U.S capital most of
those around Trump know his problems
such as bad judgment little
understanding of history and disordered
ego they're for him for their own
reasons and believe that the Democrats
and the media are worse what are your
thoughts on this and what's going to
happen with debates I think
has no reason to debate anybody he's a
big dog who's pulling at the top but I
think uh maybe afraid isn't the right
word maybe smart is a better word Trump
knows that if he gets on a debate stage
with the Sanderson and Vivek it's going
to be bad for him just in terms of he's
already pulling at the top there's no
benefit and even if he does well it only
gives them more air time that makes up
my personal opinion is I think Vivek
ramaswamy would run circles around
DeSantis and Trump at the same time he
knows way more about this he's a fast
talker he's quick-witted he you know
Trump might you know Rama swampy over
here
I didn't come up with that by the way
someone else came up with that yeah but
it's still good but you know he'll he'll
do the insults and stuff of course look
man going up against Jeb Bush Ted Cruz
and like Rubio is not the same as
DeSantis and and ramaswamy so Trump
really should avoid that really should
avoid that if if I was advising Trump I
would say Do not debate these men you
will lose because there is nothing to
gain you're the big dog right you got a
40-point lead why do it and I'm saying
Trump could actually perform very well
but he just would not be able to perform
well enough to uh he would just lose he
could only lose from this so that's your
counsel now what do you think he'll do
I think I don't know man it's tough
right because what you can go to him and
tell him like he probably shouldn't do
it he probably will because he loves the
stage oh yeah he loves a fight oh and
and maybe he's hearing this going like
then I have to beat him on the stage
then I have to do it if they think I
can't it's not I it's not that I think
Trump can't win a debate with these men
it's that it's it's he's going up
against extremely competent individuals
who are going to you know who are going
to put weights on his ankles and you
already know the media is against him so
if you if he doesn't show up to these
debates how much negative ammunition
he's chicken he's scared remember like
Back to the Future like the one word you
couldn't called Michael J fox was what
are you yeah all of a sudden Trump
scared he's a chicken he's getting you
know he Biden's not gonna debate either
no
White House like that's he's not going
to come out I think I'd like to see
Biden debate RFK Marianne Williamson I'd
like to see that I think I I think we're
I think it's we're in hot water negative
territory if the Front Runners the
incumbent president and the former
president just do not debate whatsoever
yeah I don't think that's a good look
for either candidate I think what the
media has done to RFK and Marion
Williamson is is disgusting but you know
obviously I hate the corporate press so
I despise them they're evil people so
that's that's not shocking talk about
corporate press Chris Hayes says CNN's
Trump's Town Hall decision hard to
defend this is a hill story msnbc's
Chris Hayes criticizes CNN's decision to
host former president Trump in a
lifetime Hall event next week saying he
finds it very hard to defend the choice
to give him a live platform no matter
how addressed how it is dressed up CNN
announced earlier this week that Trump
will participate in town hall event in
New Hampshire moderated by CNN anchor
Caitlin Collins Hayes warned that giving
Trump live airtime poses a risk that he
might give out personal inform Nation
about the D.A or say something that
cannot be on set MSNBC has previously
opted out of live coverage of Trump's
events despite I think Rachel Maddow was
the one that says he is speaking right
now but we don't want to have any of the
missiles we're going to tell you what he
says but we're not going to error
despite Trump's past criticism of CNN he
is reportedly looking to rebuild
immediate relationship as he runs for
re-election 2024 do you agree with Chris
Hayes it's a cult these people are in a
cult and the cult is large and you can't
pull them out because they're on social
media but one of the most powerful
tactics a cult used is to separate you
from external information when you go
back and look at all the news coverage
of Donald Trump You can conclude a few
things if you come from my background
it's man this guy's kind of a dick you
know Trump's a boisterous loud uh man
he's rude to a lot of people but those
things they claimed he did he did not do
my favorite example one of the earliest
is when they show the they zoom in on
him and he throws food into a koi pond
with Shinzo Abe of Japan then the media
just goes nuts insulting him saying how
crass how uncouth turns out they edited
the video
so that you could not see Shinzo Abe
dumps the food in the koi pond and then
Trump nods and then does the same thing
and that seemingly innocuous but the the
goal was every step of the way they were
falsely representing what it is Trump
said or did to create a an impression in
someone's mind that was not Donald Trump
he's a lot of things but uh the best
example of course is Joe Biden launching
his campaign on what we call the very
fine people hoax where Donald Trump said
you know in Charlottesville there were
uh very fine people on both sides and
I'm not talking about the white
nationalists the neo-nazis because they
should be condemned totally but you had
some people who thought the statue
should not be torn down what does Joe
Biden do completely Alters the context
puts up a fake video to to lie to people
so then you end up with people like
Chris Hayes he's an occult he might
actually be an orchestrator of the lies
probably is but when he goes out and
says you should not hear what this man
has to say don't trust people who say
that I will tell you this anybody
listening you should hear what everyone
has to say make the decision for
yourself I'm not your boss I'm Not Your
Leader I'm just some dude on the
internet you can hear what I have to say
you can tell me I'm wrong you can insult
me and call me all the names in the
world I respect that anybody who tells
you no no don't listen to that guy
they're probably tricking you or lying
to you yeah and so then when you say
that like you're on I think Brian Sharp
was on your podcast he talked about the
evil group of people that are secretly
controlling the world do you think yeah
I think I think you did who did that oh
Brian sharp was on your on your on your
podcast just as well evil people running
the world you mentioned when you said
evil about these people do you think
it's just generations of families that
are just keeping this power or is it
genuine evil that is out here because I
I don't think it's generations of
families I think there is a an emergent
effect that exists throughout Humanity
where people inherit seats of power and
then uh you know the way I've described
it is you can have a president who seems
hopeful and seems fantastic the moment
they sit down they're handed a stack of
papers by the Deep state by the CIA and
they go oh okay now we're going to keep
blowing up kids in the Middle East yeah
so you know one of the things I think
especially now with the narrative from
Tucker Carlson and Ron Paul about JFK
being assassinated the joke I've made is
that the president gets in to uh you
know to office
and then he says I want to end this war
and then you know his head of uh the CIA
just slides a photo of JFK right onto
his desk and says no you don't wow and
then he's like okay I'm joking obviously
yeah but that's what uh Tucker says so
when when you know Media Matters loves
to pull things out of context and then
lie obviously they do it all day it's
what they do for a living
here I'll read the quote not that it's
not a censorship question and people
expect me to say Jews or something no
I'm talking about like the Davos group
powerful corporate interests these are
people of all different backgrounds so I
mean like what what is the implication
here that they're trying to put on me
I'm quite literally saying this was this
was related I think to Kanye West I'm
like the idea that it's it's Jewish
people who are doing these things it's
one of the stupidest things I've ever
heard because there's uh we looked up
the banks and like the CEOs of all these
big banks are like white irish guys and
people just want to find a group of
people to blame but what I think it is
Disney Who currently runs Disney uh Bank
of America Who currently run someone
worked a job they get the promoted or
appointed and these people then just
follow like cogs in the machine
something that is the banality of evil
so there's malicious evil there's the
banality banality of evil I think
someone like ocasio-cortez is
maliciously evil in that she
intentionally decides to cause pain and
harm to people for example she told the
story about January 6 where she said
someone knocks on her door she goes and
hides in the bathroom she's thinking
they got to my office you know I'm gonna
die she hears someone say where is she
where is she turns out it was a cop and
they were vacuuming the building what
ends up happening is conservatives come
out because many of them don't do their
their research
and they said hey wait a minute aoc's
office isn't in the capital the media
then does fact check there are tunnels
that connect the capital to aoc's office
that's why she was scared and then I
come out and say double fact check the
story she told took place one hour
before the capital was breached she made
the whole thing up I'm sure a cop went
to her I think a cop did go to her
office did knock on the door did say
where's AOC and that was because they
were evacuating that particular building
an hour before anyone breached the
capital and it was over the pipe bomb
scare so when she tells a story and says
they got me they found me or something
like that she is lying to you she
intentionally chose to to lie now you've
got the story of uh the the guy who had
40 arrests who kidnapped the little girl
who punched a 64 year old man in the
face who broke a 67 year old woman's
nose who threatened people on a train
saying I'll hurt anyone and I don't care
if I go to jail and three people three
New Yorkers said we must subdue this man
and in the process the man lost his life
what is AOC now doing demanding the
victims go to prison I think that's
maliciously evil no now back to the evil
group of people ruined the world I think
it's more the banality of evil in that
it is a common place it is destructive
and the funny thing is if you actually
took the conversation that Media Matters
is so upset about and brought it to your
average leftist they would completely
agree corporations are gutting the Earth
they're destroying our forests they're
causing massive pollution yet when I say
it they try to frame it as though I'm
referring to some conspiracy or cabal
yeah
because I mean we're talking about the
spirituality of it like even with Tucker
Tucker's last speech when I figure out
where he was Pat what dinner where he
was just like listen I there's negative
people out there and he's like you got
to protect our kids and this Heritage
yeah it was it's all about to me it's
just a battle of good good and evil I
think I think you make a great point so
so let me let me ask let's talk about
jazz Jennings you've been on this Jazz
Jennings things and oh yeah you know
choice words for you if you want to uh
Tim if you if you want to just go from
the beginning uh I I this morning I
watched her video from 11 years ago I
don't know if you've seen her video from
11 years ago go type in go on YouTube
and uh if you go on YouTube and if for
some of you watching this that you don't
know who Jazz Jennings is go to YouTube
and type in jazz Jennings and then go
solve for views
um go solve for views something should
come up with 11 million views go yeah go
to filter views something should come up
with 11 million views or so go down a
little bit go down uh it's a CNN store
it's 11 years ago or 10 years ago go up
the other way go up go up go up go up go
up that one right there teenage 11 years
old yeah ABC so you know so that one
right that I watched this morning and
the way she pitches it you know at six
years old she knew she was uh you know
he knew he was stuck in a man's body and
it was a she and then Mom and Dad
supported her going through the
transition and you know and then she
takes all these pills and everything and
you see you know mermaid she swims like
mermaid but it's a boy this this this
this guy is now so parent supported that
anyways take it from here to where it's
at today he's not put on 100 pounds I
think he weighs 240 pounds 230 pounds he
responded to a lot of comments that was
said on her channel Matt wall Shapiro a
bunch of other guys what's your biggest
frustration with jazz Jennings and
DeSantis in Florida so the simple
version is I think Jazz Jennings is the
victim of severe psychological and
physical abuse from uh her family I
don't mind using you know pronouns for
someone like a for a transfer person I
have friends who are trans prone of
things nothing to me uh Jazz you you
can't be six years old and decide to
permanently sterilize yourself and
that's what happened with jazz Jennings
Jazz will never have children Jazz
underwent puberty blockers and hormone
replacement therapy which resulted in an
inability to reproduce and actually have
what I would just keep family friendly
and call adult sensation
uh the left likes respond saying how
weird that you would bring that up bro
I'm not here to be shamed I don't care
um my I'm we're talking about the future
of this country and what we are
determining to be a good or bad thing
so so if you watch the videos of uh well
let me slow down Jazz Jennings was three
years old and they said they thought
Jazz was trans at six Jazz says
obviously you mentioned I'm trans uh I I
believe at seven years old they're
showing Jazz off and and the families
doing press and stuff like that jazz the
puberty blockers prohibit the
development the adult development of a
human being in terms of their uh sexual
characteristics which results in a bunch
of very very serious and severe
complications the the reason this uh has
become more pronounced in terms of like
the reason why we're talking about it
now
several years ago when discussing the
issue of of kids and trans kids uh I
talked about how I felt Jazz would
eventually come out and be Biola and be
what we would just describe as a
straight male something that effect what
happened was Jazz before the age of
puberty was saying on TV and things like
that that uh she was attracted to boys
after this age around 13 or 14 Jess says
I'm pansexual I'm attracted to everybody
today jazz is dating women at least
according to the reports I'm unsurprised
to hear that jazz is biologically male
I'm not surprised that a biological
males attracted to females that's 98 of
biological males so when you look at a
story like that then you go back to the
story of John money John money was a
I I I don't even know what to call him
he took he was a doctor who took two
children sick Name by the way this is a
horrifyingly evil man who tortured
children okay he's not a good guy not
not a good guy at all he they were they
were they were two children David Reimer
of course and I think um uh his bro
David and I forgot the brother's name so
they were they were twin boys uh one had
a botched circumcision
John money went to the family and said
gender is a social construct if we
surgically alter the baby we can raise
this male as a female and they will
never know the difference and they'll
live a happy life John money then forced
these young children to engage in
simulated sexual acts on each other they
both ended up killing themselves when
you look at a story like that you have
some concerns about uh David Reimer
eventually committed suicide at 38 it's
very sad and his brother died of an
overdose at 36. uh so maybe they weren't
twins maybe I was wrong with it when you
look at a story like that you have
concerns about whether or not we should
surgically or medically alter children
who can't make these decisions for
themselves if a six-year-old comes to
you and says they know something it
doesn't necessarily mean they do so I'm
not going to pretend to have all the
answers but now when you look at the
story of jazz Jennings where we
currently are and my issue particularly
with the DeSantis Administration that
wanted to make this a fight I'll I'm
here uh here's what happens a video
emerges more recently
Jazz Jennings has become morbidly obese
severely depressed suffering from very
serious mental issues Jazz Jennings
mother says on the show
that she wakes Jazz up in the middle of
the night grabs the dilator lubricates
it and says if you don't stick this in
your vagina I will let me explain to you
what a dilator is when someone undergoes
what they refer to as bottom surgery it
creates a permanent wound that is not an
insult that is not meant to be derisive
it is a it is a fact statement the wound
attempts to close trans people have to
use what's called an acrylic dilator
with lubrication to force it into the
wound to make sure the wound does not
close the purpose of this wound is so
that man can penetrate it with their
penises for sexual gratification
if if jazz is not engaging in this
dilation I would make the assumption
that jazz is uninterested in keeping
this wound open Jazz's mother is on
television saying
I wake her up in the middle of the night
and say if you don't stick this in your
vagina I will in another clip Jazz's
mother says if she goes off to college
and that thing seals up I will ring her
neck
and a lot of people I got to turn a
phrase and I'm like I don't care okay if
you have a child we're now an adult
who has undergone all of these surgeries
and Jazz had several complications very
serious complications where because of
the puberty blockers sexual
characteristics do not develop you can
then not perform an actual what they
would call a penile inversion
vaginoplasty to to create a wound for
the purpose of sexual gratification of
like if if a trans person wants to have
sex right you can't do it
I look at this and say okay look I don't
I don't know where we draw the line on
whether or not Jazz as an autonomous
adult is going to say they're satisfied
with their life and we should stop there
I simply put it this way
if I'm in my apartment and I hear a man
and woman yelling and I hear pounding
and yelling I mean you might want to
investigate you know you hear a woman
screaming like ah you might want to call
the police I'm not saying you do every
single time you don't know what's going
on but I kind of I I'm kind of concerned
about if you hear muffled screaming of a
woman and a man yelling at her and then
banging and you go I'm sure there's two
sides to this I'm gonna mind my own
business that's not me that's not my
moral framework my moral framework is
either I go knock on the door and ask
them if everything's all right or I just
call the police and say look sounds like
this guy might be battering this woman
cop might show up and they were like
playing a game of Twister or something
and she's playing a race car game who
knows who knows when you have a video
where the mother says to Jazz and this
is part of the viral video that came out
you are Your Own Worst Enemy Jess says
I'm depressed I don't feel like myself I
keep going negative the mother says I
know you are Your Own Worst Enemy I'm
like well that sounds like psychological
abuse in and of itself not that much
when you then have a video of the mother
saying if you don't stick this in I will
do it well that sounds like a threat of
physical Force against a person who is
rejecting this this Medical Practice
you're imposing on them if you then say
if she does not I will ring her neck you
combine those things and I'm like I
think this woman is severely brutalizing
this this individual does that not
warrant
The Descent Administration to humbly
knock on the door and say is everything
okay can we speak with you privately it
may be in the it may be ultimately that
jazz Jennings says this is fine you're
belonging out of proportion does this
not warrant The Descent Administration
to say hey TLC we'd like to see the
footage that you have because you've
been documenting this family for a
decade because we're concerned about
potential abuse that's going on instead
what happens is when I tweet this video
and said where's Ron DeSantis this is
all happening in Florida I get a
response from Christina Pusha and Jeremy
Redfern that the Press people for uh
DeSantis Rhonda Santos doesn't have a
time machine he can't go back five years
and prevent this from happening and then
they turn it into this how dare you
criticize Ron DeSantis you're a grifter
who wants click bait and I said okay you
know what here's where I'm at
I'm sorry Christina and Jeremy and the
distance Administration I had no idea if
um if in Florida a person can go on
television and say that they're going to
force a dilator into a wound of of their
child and if they don't do it they're
going to ring their neck if that is
legal and acceptable in Florida I am
sorry I made the mistake of thinking
there should be some kind of inquiry
into whether or not that could be abuse
well my question for you guys I suppose
is play the video and then ask me if you
think this warrants
a simple question being asked with a
knock on the door
but with her I'm worried about like her
mental
well-being and her dilation the minute
she leaves my house we have a dilation
problem that is a concern when you don't
have that watchful eye they tend to go
back to Old patterns I have woken Jazz
out of a dead sleep and taken the
dilator and put the lubrication on it
and said here you take this and you put
it in your vagina if not I will but jazz
is bad even when I'm home once a day how
old is yes wait is that the mother right
now
okay Causeway to college and that thing
seals up I bring her neck can you
imagine what a demon now what do you
imagine Jazz what show is this on what
channel is this on it's TLC it's called
I think it's called IMG I got a few
questions uh legally questions I'm gonna
ask okay I know you're going hardcore at
the santis with this and he's got a
million things he's dealing with and he
I didn't even go I said where's Rhonda
Sanders I get that let me just kind of
give you my side and and trust me if
you're on if you watch our podcast some
people would say we're not a DeSantis
podcast because I challenge uh hardcore
marketing book launch anyways I'm not
gonna go there all I'm saying to you is
so number one TLC has a legal team okay
before TLC thinks this is okay to put up
their lawyers have to say no we can't
put this or else it's going to be a
lawsuit okay so every every media at
that size is gonna have something like
this like when you publish a book you've
done this before where you know the
salmon and Schuster Loyals will come in
and say yeah this story you have have to
use a different name you can use this
person's name because it's going to be
Allah so we won't have nothing to do
with it okay great so you can go
independently you know launch it or you
can go through them but their lawyers is
going to have that call with you so
check I don't know what TLC did their
responsibility number two
if jazz is 22 and uh she is defending in
that one reaction video she made she
says my mom's the best mom in the world
no she didn't do anything wrong I'm not
regretting any of my decisions right now
she did the right thing because I'm so
glad she did that I'm just a depressed
person I'm just going through hard times
in my life I've always been like this
and so she defends that so that kind of
is if you're saying the person next door
that you go to a husband and wife it's
you know sort of loud you know what's
going on I want to go defend and then
she said we're just having rough sex and
that's we do that every night so unless
move your apartment to a different place
or you can hear this every now because
this is how we have sex and we're ever
happy about it now what do you say now
okay you can now defend it so if the
daughter who's now 22 an adult is saying
this that's not something that you know
they can do anything with you know if
it's a kid to me the concern is five
years ago if it's 22 that's why they're
saying five years ago because she was
17. yeah at that time you're 100 right I
don't under my problem isn't with TLC my
problem is the 11 years ago ABC
showing it with the verbiage that
they're using making it seem like this
is okay and then now this person's being
turned into a hero as a mother and other
people are watching this and you're
hearing stories about how Dwyane Wade to
defend the santis if there's anything
that you're getting with people that
have trans kids the scientist is running
Florida okay Dwyane Wade comes out and
is being interviewed I don't know if you
saw this one or not just recently he
said well you know I just you know as
much as I love Florida and you know we
love the no taxes and a lot of great
things over there we have a lot of great
uh friends
I just didn't feel safe for my child and
all this other stuff and now we're going
to move in they're living in L.A right
now because he's doing a whole Hollywood
thing himself Gabrielle all that stuff
great that's a choice that he made but
that to me would be the ultimate example
of what a group what a job DeSantis is
doing with the state of Florida that is
forcing people like this to say like
where does Jazz Jennings live right now
are they living in Florida Broward
virtual school by the way is 15 minutes
away in Coconut Creek and and you can go
there right now and the mother is good
and the mother the whole family lives
here that's where they're at I believe
yeah okay yeah so so for them go ahead
oh no I I I want to you can finish I'm
sorry yeah TLC The Lawyers the age where
she's at today the Santa's five years
ago I mean let me let me let me give you
a hypothetical if uh if you saw a video
of a father
I'm an adult man says every day I wake
up my daughter and I grab the penetrator
and say you stick this in your vagina or
I'll do it would you arrest would you
would you go and be like okay hold on
there a minute like let's let's let's go
have a conversation with this family I I
would contact that Media company to say
what makes you think this is normal for
you to play well and and I would I would
want to uh I would want to investigate
the parents that are doing that at the
time uh yes knock on the door knock on
the door is everything okay here I mean
that that sounded kind of like what's
the context of writer now I understand
the response is the dilation is a
medical practice that jazz must right
must do but if Jazz isn't doing it does
not imply jazz is uninterested in doing
it and saying you're going to ring their
neck or hold or or do it don't forget
and twisted I I understand exactly what
you're saying and I'm with you I mean
there's no let me address the law
enforcement thing uh victims don't
prosecute the state does uh the victim
is not necessary in the prosecution of a
crime if the police are made aware of a
crime it doesn't not matter what the
victim says if a woman is battered by
her husband and there is a witness the
police can say ma'am I understand you're
claiming it was just rough sex you do it
all the time but we have witnesses
saying he was beating you in the face
and they will still if they choose to
arrest that man I don't know about that
this is not a strong case the reason why
it's not a strong case is because
there's thousands of videos like this of
parents who have said things like this
about their kids and people take it as a
joke to me this is this is uh this is
catastrophic that the mother is turned
into a hero to me that mother is a
disaster and a in a menace to society
because other mothers look at her as a
as a what do you call it as a hero so I
would say I understand your argument I
understand what you're saying somebody
my argument is knock on the door I
didn't say criminally charge him and and
for for one thing on the Twitter front I
said where is Ron DeSantis you know what
Christina and Jeremy could have said hey
Tim Rhonda Santos made this illegal
we'll take a look at what you're talking
about thank you have a nice day instead
they turned it into Tim's grifter and a
liar you know Rhonda Sanchez doesn't own
a time machine I don't even know about
that
partial here before and you know I'm not
here defending push-up we last time I
spoke to push-up was the last time she
was here so I don't know whatever that
time was uh no but what what I'm my
argument back to you is with that yeah
could they have handled in a different
way sure if if you if you and I went and
interviewed
top 100 most liberal Americans who are
all about this transgender community and
we ask them name me the number one state
or Governor that you feel the least
safest to be able to do anything you
want to do with trans and lgbtq and
teaching kids about these types of
things at an early age I'm willing to
bet a hundred thousand dollars that a
hundred out a hundred will have floored
in their top three agreed yeah yeah so
so the point is that that credit goes to
the guy at the top that's getting a lot
of heat for what he's doing to fight
some of these battles matter of fact
I'll give you an idea so Peter Thiel who
is a supporter of Ronda santis comes out
and says Peter Theo likes Ron DeSantis
for president but has one worry this is
a Daily Beast story has one worry what's
the worry that around that Peter Thiel
has this is a very smart guy Peter
Republican megadona Peter Thiel sees
potentially around the center saying
that the Florida governor would make a
terrific president but he did say that
he liked the sentence as the GOP nominee
with one stipulation if he's a
republican nominee I will strongly
support him in 2024 but I do worry that
focusing on the woke issue is Ground
Zero uh as ground zero is not quite
enough the sentences war on wokeness has
been the Crux
of his political platform as of late he
infamously touted Florida as a place
where woke goes to die in a January
speech support the anti-lgbtq policies
such as the don't don't say gay Bill law
have largely defined his tenure as
governor in fact that's it's that very
law that landed him in the ongoing feud
with Disney which has drawn the hour of
old school conservatives who uh believe
the governor shouldn't be so willing to
piss off a big Corporation okay fine so
he says this yet his friend Dave Rubin
moved his podcast here and lives in
Miami feels safe over here Dave rubin's
very close to Ron DeSantis Dave is part
of the LGBT 2 Community as a man that
identifies himself as a gay man and we
we've had him on we were just with him I
think two weeks ago or something like
that and we like Dave a lot yeah so so
even a Peter Thiel saying this and Peter
Thiel said five years ago if I was
moving here from Silicon Valley I would
have gone a house for nothing today
whatever you paid for house in Miami is
now four times the price there is no
point of moving from Silicon Valley here
to Miami because the houses are just as
expensive as they are in Silicon Valley
this is something the sentence
so so again what what he is saying
he is saying the people that don't like
it are leaving
so this kind of validates a part of you
know that that Community the whole woke
thing I think a lot of parents are
sitting on listen he got criticism for
the whole six-week thing with the
abortion that was a a lot of Republicans
said what are you doing like I talk to
wives and mothers and they're Republican
they're conservative they say they said
what was the point of doing that that
was like the first time we saw he missed
the Mark when he did that you didn't
need to do that there was no winning
with that did you end up winning the
biggest biggest conservative Republicans
what percentage is that five percent not
ten percent you didn't need to do that
fine that was he missed that one but in
this year parents are liking the fact
that there's somebody who has the
audacity to go up against the distance
to go up against what they're trying to
do in schools so there is a community
that's supporting what he's doing but
even Peter thiel's give him some
criticism I think I think Tio's wrong
I mean you look at the Double D you look
at the million million vote Victory
margin for Rhonda Santa says Governor
you look at the mass Exodus from New
York and California into Florida and
then I think second place is Texas uh
Ronda Santos is the best Governor this
country has right I agree so so me me
saying where it says on an issue of jazz
Jennings being horribly misconstrued to
imply that I'm like I think he's doing a
bad job I think he's doing a fantastic
job the question is on this one moral
issue that's been happening to go viral
what's what what's their current
position that it's too late that the
abuse that may be happening ongoing in
Florida it's too late I think the issue
is it's a it's a very very dangerous
subject you know Rhonda Sanderson
Administration are willing to to tackle
these issues loudly and clearly but not
a mainstream celebrity personality it's
too much for them they can't handle that
kind of heat I that's not a
consideration for me when it comes to an
issue so you're saying he's afraid to go
after mainstream media you think Jazz
Jennings is that big of a mainstream
person this guy's going after Disney
knock on the door he's causing the
greatest Miami Heat of all time to leave
Miami bro why why why why why the
negative reaction so heavily from his PR
people maybe maybe they have looked at
it with their legal team and they're
saying there's nothing here why don't
they say that maybe they don't want to
say it for different reasons maybe they
don't want to say it because they're
dealing with other things maybe they're
sitting there saying this isn't
something that we want to tackle right
now because why not just not respond at
all by the way if there's anything I
will be on the same page with you I
don't think they have the best marketing
team so so that that's a whole different
thing where for me I think they can hire
a much better marketing team than what
they have right now will criticize that
non-stop all-day you know until they
either hero or they do something about
it this marketing team is not going to
take him to the next level they need a
real market like you need to have real
marketers they don't have marketing
they're playing the the safe game just
too protective and it's kind of like let
it rip let's go so anyways when when
Trump was facing the indictment Ron
DeSantis if I here's what I do if I was
governor and I'm not saying I'm right
about everything you can say I'm wrong I
got up at the podium and say mark my
words there will not be an uh an
extradition of Donald Trump from my
state no finger will be laid on this man
and thank you and have a nice day
instead he's like I don't know what goes
into paying off a porn star I'm not
going to be involved in this and I just
thought that was particularly weak in
turn you know so
um what do I like about Trump the reason
I vote for him not because I think he's
the greatest leader we've ever had I
think his foreign policy has been
absolutely fantastic considering
presence we've had in the past Obama
like blown up kids like Abdullahi a 16
year old American citizen we murdered
anyway uh Donald Trump's gonna fire
everybody he wants revenge and I think
if the one thing I can get out of the
next presidency is the purging of the of
the bureaucratic class this country will
be better off for it I don't know if
Rhonda Sanders would do that I think
he's a negotiator I think he's going to
go in and say how can we make this clean
and and it's going to be like Trump's
first term all over again they're going
to attack him they're going to smear him
they're going to lie they're going to
get their key positioned people to to
sludge everything up I think at this
point with Donald Trump he's he's
Unleashed he's so angry he's been
slighted he's been lied about they've
impeached him they're trying to
criminally prose they're Prosecuting him
in in New York they're trying to get him
in DC they're trying to get him in
Georgia now they're accusing him of a 30
year old rape case I mean these people
are Relentless and almost every single
time these stories turn to be fake or
even worse it's them I mean the alpha
Bank Russia stuff was a lie Trump being
a Soviet asset Jonathan chick
congratulations that was the most
ridiculous thing I've ever heard on
cable TV all of it a lie Ukraine gate
Joe Biden saying if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars which he admitted to at a CFR
meeting
everything they say about Trump turns
out to be a misconstrued I think Trump
gets a like that he walks in and says I
don't care how I don't care uh uh why we
are going to terminate these people
we're going to send them out with nice
little boxes full of their belongings
and we're going to we're going to figure
out how to do it he wants to schedule a
laugh
that's the number one thing this country
needs right now I don't think DeSantis
does it so I got a question for you with
that so the uh Fox is now paying what
787 to a Dominion whatever the number is
that's a big number they're probably the
biggest ever 20 they're savings four
billion on the bank they're paying 787
there's a lot of different stories why
Tim all of these things that they got
wrong on the left Russia collusion you
know he did this he I mean one after
another after another impeaching them
twice just trying to publicly humiliate
him non-stop right
the vaccine comes two days after
election you know everything was timed
in such a weird way to want to hurt the
guy if Fox is paying 787 and CNN MSNBC
ABC CBS all of these guys kept talking
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia isn't
that a case to sue them for fake news
and make them do similar things that
happen with Fox and if yes why don't
they do it oh I mean they're so much
better at this than conservatives in the
right if you come out and you make a
statement that is opinion about Donald
Trump who's gonna what are you gonna say
we got times V Sullivan you're not going
to get anywhere Fox News made statements
about a massive multinational
corporation
well a massive multinational corporation
is going to fire back with all of their
resources and they're going to win you
mean Dominion in this opinion right and
not not to mention I think there's also
the smartmatic lawsuit that's happening
right behind them the hills of that it
these these uh these Fox personalities
who who came out and and made these
claims or or pushed them or brought
people on it's just
it's it's a these are these are fact
statements about companies that had
limited basis in reality right Limited
in that they'll take a mortal truth
they'll stretch it out I think Fox was
interested in fanning the Flames of
their base to to tell the story and it
backfires
you get a similar thing with CNN MSNBC
but but these people are very clever in
how they've how they do it how they've
always done it selectively editing a
video and targeting Donald Trump okay
Donald Trump as an individual is gonna
have a lot harder of a Time suing 17
News organizations but here's the best
part
says the only news organization or the
principal in this organization that was
having these conversations about
Dominion puts them in a particularly
weak State there was a story that NBC
News wrote about me that was fabricated
they then deleted the source from the
article however too late several other
articles copied the story and reposted
it creating a circular news reference
where
hey look man we didn't say it we
reported that news organization Ace said
it you can't sue us
then and they'll say it's a fact
statement it's it is a it you know if I
file a lawsuit against them it's going
to cost me 100 grand for for just
launching the suit against all these
different organizations 17 of them and
then all they have to do is set your
honor we are simply reporting what the
New York Times said it is not our
statement in New York Times at your
honor we're simply reporting what
Washington Post said and the Washington
Post say what NBC said in NBC NBC will
say what the New York Times said
creating a circular Loop of of lies that
you're you're it's impossible to fight
against are you using it as a metaphors
basically that's what happened with if
Trump tried to do a lawsuit against the
mainstream media they would basically do
exactly what you just said the gist of
it it gets more complicated I mean these
are uh it it'll it'll come down to uh
individual circumstance I'll give you
one example of right now Tucker Carlson
what CNN did they're very clever these
people uh Tucker Carlson has that Viral
text message where he said this is not
how white men fight the text message was
in its entirety Tucker Carlson saying he
was watching a video of a guy being
beaten and he found himself cheering for
it until he realized it's a horrible
thing to think people shouldn't think
these things and that I you know I don't
want to be this
CNN did a very clever thing where they
took the first half which sounds very
very horrible
put at the top of the article
filled the rest of the article with
regurgitated facts about Dominion the
lawsuit statements that nobody wants to
reread for the 18th time and then the
conclusion of Tucker's statement at the
bottom I think this might actually be
there is this the article so
you see the first quote right there in
the second paragraph a couple of weeks
ago I was watching of people fighting on
the street in Washington you then they
stop it I could taste it they stop the
quote the next up you'll notice the next
several hundred words are just old news
nobody wants to reread you then scroll
to the bottom and see the conclusion
look how far down you got it the
conclusion somewhere deep in my brain an
alarm went off isn't good for me the
reason is these news organizations know
the percentage to which people will read
these articles I believe there's a
possibility this is intentionally
formatted in such a strange way to break
apart Tucker Carlson's quotes put old
news in between so the average person
stops reading and says I already know
this and leaves the only impression in
their mind Tucker Carlson cheered
Carlson cheered for the death of an of
an individual
this is how the media gets away with
lying but you can't sue them over it
like look what media matter said about
me Tim pool says an evil you know evil
people are ruling the world or whatever
yeah if I went to Greta tunberg and said
do you think oil companies are in
control of the world she'd say
absolutely they have politicians do you
think they're evil yes of course they
are okay but you see how they do it
[Laughter]
secretly controlling the world
they meet the media for you they are
they are factual but not truthful can I
go back to you to your Trump Michael
malice who was on here not too long ago
funny guy
um go back to your Trump statement so
let's say I agree with you let's say a
lot of people agree with you about
basically the media's been coming after
him and then everything that came with
Russia gate and everything that happened
with January 6 everything everything
we're on the same page there we don't
need to relegate that and then he does
get reelected and he does come back and
drain the swamp again you're basically
you're in favor of him firing everybody
starting over again which I think a lot
of people would like to see what I want
to ask you is because someone who's not
on team Trump you're not on team
DeSantis you're on team logic at this
point give me the other side of it right
the good would be fire everybody start
over like have people held accountable
give me the other side of a mean
vindictive angry Trump looking for
Retribution and rightfully so in some
cases how would that affect America in
some regard you know if if Trump comes
in and says it's payback time [__]
what would that look like for America
great it would be the best thing ever I
don't think there's a negative I think
we're talking about is a bunch of kids
playing on a playground a bunch of
bullies who have been going around
shoving the kids in the mud they shove
Donald Trump in the money gets up and
since it's payback and all the kids are
sitting on the playground watching this
one guy go back and get revenge on the
bullies I don't think it affects us
negative at all in fact I think it'll
make things better I think he'll secure
our borders I think the economy will
greatly improve I think he'll bring jobs
back I think you take a look at the
foreign policy of Donald Trump and uh
I didn't vote for Trump in 2016. I
thought he was Despicable
um then he started enacting policies
that I was very happy to see and I still
found him to be quite despicable he's
he's a he's a potty mouth guy he's nasty
he imitated body slamming a journalist
and I'm like I don't care if you don't
like reporters I don't like the
corporate press you know don't do that
um but you know I remember uh first
simply Abraham Accords historical
amazing
um crossing the DMZ into North Korea
with no security detail one of the
greatest acts of leadership I have seen
in my life and I think should be in any
other circumstance they would they would
be writing about it it would be the one
of the most proud moments of the United
States Donald Trump entered North Korea
enemy territory with no security detail
with Kim Jong-un surrounded by North
Korean soldiers
and it was funny when I watched that
happen having a family history that goes
to Korea and what that means to me
and I was nearly brought to tears and
then the media insulted Donald Trump
over that and that really pissed me off
when Barack Obama was President he uh
ordered a drone strike on a civilian
restaurant in Yemen a country we are not
at war with which killed Abdul Rahman
al-alaki a 16 year old American citizen
no one bats an eye he also killed Anwar
al-alaki in the argument he was a Jihadi
so it's War so it's Justified I still
don't think you can kill American
citizens just because we're at War
bombing a country without a war with you
know what people come to me and say Tim
it's War we're dealing with terrorist
factions we've got allies in the region
it's conflict you cannot claim it's
murder and I'm just like
I guess but don't come to me and then
insult Donald Trump for negotiating with
Kim Jong-un when you were bombing
civilians so I look at the North Korea
thing and it's and it's I wonder if I I
wonder about the the perspectives of
other people
who know exactly what it is to have a
family saying here's where we're from
here's the town your grandfather grew up
in because I have that somewhat on one
side of my family and not on the other
because I hear the story of oh you know
your your great grandfather was from
this this town in North Korea but we
have no idea because since the since the
splitting of the country that's it we're
cut off
let me give you some credit
um and I'll tell you why I want to give
you credit is because Pat started the
entire podcast with basically your
Evolution politically right ideology
ideologically you've been all over the
map and you're you're kind of finding
your your groove right now but what
you're able to do is you're able to
separate personality from policy and
most people in America are just straight
up voting for their team they're voting
for their Jersey they're voting for the
personality they agree with they don't
go through the Nuance of policy right
here and essentially what you're saying
is you you actually to use your words
you actually found him to be disgusting
and vulgar and a whole host of words I
think you said Despicable at one point
but you still vote for them because
you're able to separate the personality
from the policy why can't most people do
that
I mean humans are social creatures you
know we we don't know everything about
everything uh the average person doesn't
know what's going on in the world
because it's not their job to and I
don't blame them for it I'm not going to
ask a plumber to read the news 24 7 all
day every day like I do yeah and so the
best thing they can do is say do I trust
this guy does he appear genuine to me
Barack Obama very much did so and for me
coming off of the Bush years of war and
ex and Military expansion in the Middle
East which was unjustified
to then be told Obama was the guy who
was going to put a stop to the unjust
Wars to see him ramp it up and then to
bomb kids the disposition the Obama had
something called the disposition Matrix
the kill list I don't know if you guys
are familiar with every Tuesday they
give him baseball card style sheets
saying like who do you want to kill
he made the decision to kill him Kobe
had one too
Kobe had Kobe Bryant it's a different
story
yeah he's throwing you off and so I just
see that I'm like I was lied to it's all
the same what's the point 2016 comes
around Donald Trump's running against
Hillary and I was just laughing the
whole time I was like this is America
the reality TV Real Estate Mogul against
the Deep State witch yes who said she
did not care if we went to war with
Russia because she wanted to own Syria
what a disgusting person and uh then
Donald Trump gets in
third party no I didn't vote I said
what's the point and uh probably looking
back on it I mean who was it um who was
the libertarian before Joe Jokers uh
Gary Johnson yeah and then he had the
Aleppo moment what is Aleppo I know the
[__] City and Tim it's crazy that you
say that about Barack doing all the war
and all the bombing of the innocent kids
Trump crossed the DMZ and shook hands
and everything guess who got the Nobel
Peace Prize Obama got the peace Donald
Trump strike a bunch of countries drone
struck or whatever uh Donald Trump or uh
ordered a Commando raid in Yemen which
according to family members resulted in
the death of abdullahi's seven-year-old
sister an American citizen
so there's there's challenges even with
Donald Trump so that's why I'm like look
you know you you're never gonna find
someone who is a saint who's doing
everything right right however Donald
Trump no new Wars Donald Trump Abraham
Accords Donald Trump withdrawal from uh
well the timeline for the withdrawal
from Afghanistan butchered by by uh Joe
Biden the dismantling of Isis the
crushing of Isis the removal of our
troops from Syria despite the fact that
the U.S uh top brass lied to us and
Donald Trump to keep troops in Syria and
then as soon as Biden gets in troops go
right back in the challenging thing for
the American people is there's no way
they're going to know about the history
of the region there's no way I could and
there's no way they're going to know
about why we're at war in Ukraine so all
they can really do is say am I with the
am I with the people or am I against the
people what I view as the woke left
is not ideological the woke to me means
cult-like adherence to Liberal social
Orthodoxy crafted by social media
algorithms that's why they're somewhat
Marxist but also pro-war in Ukraine
Ukraine has supporting war in Ukraine
has no basis in critical theory or
anything like that so you have these
right-wing academics and liberal
academics who are like oh woke means
Marxist and all that I'm like it doesn't
explain why they're so supportive of
going to war in Ukraine like it's really
just adherence to the social Orthodoxy
because it's a survival tactic of human
beings I think if the average person
actually knew it was going on they would
all immediately oppose the war in
Ukraine they would I mean you don't like
Vladimir Putin they would immediately
agree with Donald Trump on most of his
foreign policy they'd probably vote for
him again but most people don't know
that they rely on the lies of people
like Hillary Clinton blinken or or Joe
Biden and that's the challenge what can
you expect them to do if they don't have
the time to read all of these news
reports all of these scientific studies
what can they do but this goes back to
Pat's initial point go buy a [__]
media outlet and get your narrative out
there yeah but you know just like we
just circle back to Vice George Soros is
funding Vice I mean not like not a Jeff
Bezos wapo anything like that I mean
extreme far left so
you kind of said that Republicans are
just kind of minding their own business
they're buying buildings they're buying
businesses they're buying corporations
but they're not buying media Outlets
like Trump's not a republican he's an
Insurgent candidate who entered the
Republican party because it was the only
path to win he was a moderate New York
liberal and even vox.com in 2015 and
2016 called Trump a moderate candidate
and if Trump wasn't a billionaire he
probably could run as a Democrat and win
the problem is tax the rich Bernie
Sanders he wasn't going to get that base
so Trump campaigned for the Lost
Americans people who never voted before
and independent voters and he won them
over they come into the Republican party
and start pushing people out Trump also
converted nine million Obama voters into
Republican voters this pushes the
Republican establishment back Trump
would not have won among Republican
establishment voters hence why you see
people like Bill Crystal and and uh you
know the Lincoln project people now
supporting Democrat candidates because
that's closer to where they were in
terms of establishment politics
yeah could you imagine uh this is why
people were so aligned with either a
Bernie or a trump back in 2016. so you
know it's funny he's saying that Trump
claims you know he would end the war in
Ukraine and one day it would be easy
this is the story from independent or
Trump class claimed he would end the
Russia War if he was President the
former president described the situation
as a disaster
if I were president and I say this I
will end the war and one day it would
take 24 hours I know zelinski well I
know Putin well I would get that ended
in a period of 24 hours it would be easy
the deal would be easy which do you
agree with 100 tell me what Trump's
gonna go to Putin and say we are ending
all support for the ukrainians in this
in this matter
what here are the concessions we're
going to make I imagine what people need
to understand about what this means
Trump likely hands over Don bass to to
Russia hands over Sebastopol Crimea to
Russia confirmed done end of story the
the the the history of what's going on
in this region is very very complicated
the average person probably doesn't know
and I can only go so far back there's
something called the cutter turkey
pipeline back in 2009 the CIA intended
to oust the Assad regime uh because they
would not allow us to build a natural
gas pipeline through Syria turkey into
Europe to offset Russia's natural gas
Monopoly in Ukraine so what ends up
happening is
Western Powers go to Syria say hey we
want to build this pipeline it's going
to go through Sierra through turkey they
say no explicitly we are allied with
Russia and that would be against their
interests
what then happens is I think it was Iran
and uh and Russia say let's build our
own version of this pipeline tapping the
same natural gas source and running it
up bolstering our natural gas control
into Europe
there's a lot of reasons for why the the
West was upset about it one of them is
that the the point of the EU and the
reason they want cheap energy is so they
can economic they can develop
economically faster to compete with
China
when they were looking at this massive
dependence on high-cost Russian natural
gas and an inability to get any
alternatives into Europe they said let's
end Syria
fortunately for the West a civil war
just happened to have broken out you
know for whatever reason and we were on
the opposite side of that Isis then
emerges Syria destabilizes how very
convenient Joe Biden a form uh Joe
Biden's son becomes a board member at an
energy company in Ukraine surprise
surprise also a former CIA director is
also on the board of barisma Joe Biden
then goes to Ukraine and tells the
president if you don't fire the
prosecutor Victor shock and you're not
getting a billion dollars in loan
guarantees which is illegal I might add
the vice president does not have the
authority to stop congressionally
approved loan guarantees to another
country but hey they impeach Donald
Trump for that but you know okay that
Joe Biden did it I think the the
principal reason of what's Happening
Here is we Russia is impeding our
ability to expand in Europe economically
nordstream 2 for instance who blew that
up likely uh I think what it is maybe
sales probably I think they're saying it
was CIA assisted but it was like uh the
British perhaps um I got to follow they
don't have a clear answer as I think but
it's not that's stupid blowing up their
own pipeline yeah that's right
ridiculous but all of this is it's very
obvious that we have a dependence on
Russian gas we're trying to resist and
so what happens with Ukraine NATO's been
expanding into Eastern Europe for a very
very long time Estonia Latvia on the
border of Russia Russia has its only
warm water port in savastapol Crimea
which gives them access to the Black Sea
to the Mediterranean and then outward a
lot of trade goes through there and then
what happens the euromidan protests
emerge and the people of Ukraine are now
split pro-russia pro-eu most of them
leaning towards pro-eu that's my per
that's what I've seen from the data and
in my personal experience having been on
the ground when that was happening and
talking to the people of Kiev even
random people saying we don't trust
Russia we know the history of the Soviet
Union the holiday more we want to be
with the EU
so when Russia sees that happening what
people need to understand is that uh
shouted Dave Smith Russia did not in the
immediate invade quote unquote this is
back in I think 2014 they were already
in Crimea in Sebastopol they simply
walked out of the base and said hey
we're here now you can argue the
referendum was fake and all that but
what do you think Russia is going to do
if NATO seeks to expand into a country
and the EU when that's their only warm
water port and access to the Black Sea I
mean it's fight time that's it so you
can argue that Russia started the fight
you can argue and people say no NATO did
people say no Russia did I'm like dude
if if Russia started putting troops in
Mexico and then threatened to cut off
the U.S access in the Gulf the U.S is
going to be them fighting words yep and
then especially if if more importantly
if Russia already controlled a large
portion of the Border like NATO controls
you know NATO was in Estonia and Latvia
Russia is already angry about this
it's it you it doesn't matter who you
blame it matters a fight will happen and
that's where we are I think Trump goes
in negotiates it pisses off uh Ukraine
it pisses off Russia but it ends the
fight and
example forgets but uh so then if Trump
doesn't
and Trump doesn't win do you think war
of Russia is inevitable with the way
that things were going on with Russia I
I agree but I'm saying it's already on
the ground 100 the the first we got the
story from The Intercept they kept
denying it it's um it's not it's not
like it's the most people in the world I
think it's a special force it's NATO
Special Forces and several dozen yeah uh
but now it's been it's been leaked it's
it's it's true
the US is providing intelligence to you
here's what's happening right yep
if if you and your neighbor are fighting
with each other and then I walk up to
you and I hand you a big old pile of
rocks and I tell you where to throw them
do you think your neighbor is gonna be
like that guy's not involved at all he's
gonna be like this dude is the one so
we're arming Ukraine we're telling them
where to shoot their missiles yeah the
United States provided the Intel to
Ukraine to sink the Black Sea Flagship
of Russia the idea that Russia as Putin
is going man how is how is Ukraine
beating us it's absurd Putin is saying
NATO is at war with us using the
ukrainians as cannon fodder American
citizens as quote unquote volunteers
military trained and armed are on the
ground in in it's it's the most
ridiculous thing in the world but people
live in this reality where because
there's no formal declaration that means
United States veteran troops armed by
the United States
that means we're not actually at War
like I'm sorry dude you can't have PM
private military contractors quote
unquote volunteers from United States
and Western countries fighting a war
funded by you armed by you and then
expect to believe Russia thinks they're
not fighting you
like Russia and Russian television
outright said we are at war with NATO
and I and I do believe that Putin will
use nuclear weapons but people need to
understand nuclear weapon does not mean
ICBM reigning Hellfire in a city sure
tactical Nuclear artillery did you did
you see what happened of course the
bubble the the what do you call it now
the balloon that came down and attempted
uh do you have to clip wrap if you can
draw a drone drone coming down Tim if
you can look at this here uh Tim right
here oh right the crown is it so while
you're finding that can you go find the
uh the video of um
of the bubble coming in uh um
okay God if you can okay yeah play that
if you can so the audience can see it
oh the Drone strike yeah this just
happened a couple days ago
okay so so question
who's involved well you know this is
Putin doing it because he wants to say
that there's an attack so he can use
this as a leverage point to attack uh
Ukraine and he can say well I'm just
reacting to it no it was really they
were attempting to do to go after him
you know this was Ukraine's job you know
they're trying to get him to an attempt
on assassination well if that is the
case why would you do it that way that's
not even that big that's not a big deal
that's somehow you're going to kill the
guy no it was U.S involved no it's an
outsider no it says and what do you
think all the stuff here with this with
the spoon here first it doesn't matter
who did it or why they did it all that
matters is there's a video Russia said
the US did it Russia will escalate on
that pretext we can then get into the
argument of you know did he fake it did
he not I think people underestimate uh
what we're seeing you know the
conversation we've had is like what is
that even doing what is that small thing
why did it explode where it exploded
well I believe they shot it down but uh
the scary thing about these drones is
they can carry powerful explosives they
can swarm
this
it could be a false flag there's no
there's no real way to know it could be
Russia saying send in a single drone my
question is if it was Ukraine how did
they launch this attack where did they
launch it from but it does fall in line
with with what you would actually expect
to see in terms of this kind of warfare
you're not going to see Ukraine firing
missiles from Ukrainian territory into
the air targeting Moscow or anything
like that yeah you're going to see
Guerrilla tactics and small-scale
Insurgency style sabotage and attacks
like this this could have been a
Ukrainian a Ukrainian or a Ukrainian
sympathetic Russian or any other foreign
mercenary who had a drone we don't I
don't know how big that drone was I'm
not sure if it was the size of a car or
whatever but you can you can do these
things with very small consumer drones
they can carry explosive it's terrifying
it could be that someone James Bond
style and who went to Moscow put the
thing on the ground ran away and then
waited an hour and then someone remotely
activated launched it and went and tried
to take out Putin yeah and mind you that
whoever was flying I mean it didn't it
didn't really didn't even make the flag
go down it didn't really penetrate
anything so whoever's no why no one's
flying it yeah probably nobody just by
itself automatic people have said um you
know cut off the signal now these things
have a GPS in them it knows where it is
and where it needs to go even if you cut
off its access to GPS the internet it
already has a mapped trajectory the only
thing I'm saying is let's play a
propaganda okay if you're Putin and
you're behind this and you did this and
then you attack Ukraine guess what you
can say listen you don't do that to us
you can allow them to do something like
that to us we have to stay strong we
can't have them think about this so what
prompted me showing this clip is when
you said I think Putin is going to use
nuclear and nuclear it's not what you
think it is that all the stuff you're
going through okay
if if NATO keeps pushing the envelope
and they're getting involved and they're
saying no we're not involved no no we're
not involved no we're not no listen
you're involved and this is a war that
it's you against Russia it's not really
I saw something the other day a picture
of a great funny meme uh that says uh uh
let me show you how to work from home
and make 40 billion dollars
it's freaking hilarious that is
hilarious I'll I'll send it to you rob
you have to show this as one of the
funnier memes I've seen this week I sent
it to Mario it tells you how much Mario
loves politics Mario says Pat I don't
get it I'm like it's okay don't worry
it's a Rob I'll send it to uh I'll text
you to you it's worth watching so but
the point is if if um Russia and I did
this intentional intentionally to attack
if in the next three four five days
Russia does attack Ukraine in a major
way
I mean there's got to be a percentage to
be thinking about this was strategic I
don't know if it was a false flag I mean
I'll I could go back and forth because
it's impossible to know
but I think Russia would have already
made a declaration if they they said the
U.S was behind this they're the ones in
in who are who are pushing this
this is actually really really bad for
Russia if they're unprepared for full
scare full-scale war with NATO
so the the strategy man it could go A
Million Ways let's imagine the scenario
the United States wants to force Russia
to to declare war on us so that we can
formally enter so that the United States
can take all of everything it has and
put it in Ukraine how do you make that
happen this is the worst thing that
could have happened to Putin a pathetic
failed attempt which they are now forced
to say was us and they will do nothing
about it I think that if it was actually
a false flag they probably I don't know
crash a plane into the Kremlin or
something like like blow up a large
portion of it with a cruise missile and
then say they they directly attacked us
it's there look it's on camera they'd
blast the video everywhere this is a
pathetic little drone two of them
blowing up and nothing happens
if it was the US who did it and Russia
said it is here's the world stage the
United States according to Russia just
tried to kill its president and Russia
says
we can't do anything about it makes them
look weak and it's going to scare their
allies thinking they're they're going to
lose this one who am I betting on which
horse so that's why I you know
ultimately I don't know I don't know I
think a false flag from Russia would
have been stronger and they would have
immediately made some kind of move and
they don't need an assassination attempt
on Putin to justify nuclear artillery
use or strikes in in Ukraine because
striking Ukraine when they're blaming
the US doesn't make sense so on the on
the premise of that they're look they're
looking weak you know I think when this
war started nobody wants to see this war
by the way I mean and generally speaking
like people are actually dying on the
ground it's hundreds of thousands of
people it's very sad but I think when
this thing started we think Russia is
just going to Pummel Ukraine they're
just going to take over this country
it's done
and then fast forward it's been a year
and a half
Ukraine's holding its own apparently
Russia is basically Outsourcing half
their military or a large portion of
this Wagner group whoever this is
they're basically pulling people out of
the [__] prison to start fighting for
them you have mothers protesting that
there's the sons are dying for a war
they don't want a part of where'd you
hear that right well this is mainstream
media well this is where you're hearing
it from but this Wagner this Wagner
group is a real group that they are
basically Outsourcing are they not yeah
well I mean if you believe the American
corporate press which I tend to even
though I'm very critical of it I do fact
check these things and we have to we
have to get our information from
somewhere that's a difficult thing to do
uh looking at various sources around the
world to try and figure out what string
what's not if you go to Russian sources
they'll tell you the exact opposite of
what you just said well you can't trust
anything that comes out of our tears
Russian sources can you trust anything
coming out of the New York Times and
they claimed that Trump was working for
Russia yeah no and at the same time Adam
did you know like they thought it was
going to happen like overnight he was
going to take them over I don't think
anybody expected us to send them
billions of dollars tanks troops and all
that I mean but the UK is sending in
depleted uranium tank Busters which
Russia has already said that is an
escalation to the use of nuclear force I
agree I guess I guess my point is I'm
more I'm not saying that I believe
everything that comes out of the
corporate love media at all I think at
this point we've all just we realized
that the rush foreign
I tend to believe New York Times more
than Russian propaganda there's levels
to lie Russia calls the New York Times
American propaganda exactly so so Russia
has its interests the US has its
interests I think Putin is a bad dude I
think Putin's a substantially worse dude
than Joe Biden is and I think Joe
Biden's a pretty bad dude so if I had
Joe Biden in front of me and Vladimir
Putin in front of me and Joe Biden said
here's what's happening I'd be like you
know I think you're both full of it but
I'm gonna go buy on this one even though
I don't like the guy yeah so I agree
that the question is when it comes to
the granular nature of all of the news
coming out the US is lying to you right
you can't trust anything they say it
would be the stupidest military strategy
in the world to tell the public what
you're doing in war or why you're doing
it you'd lose in two seconds
so that just means whether we like Biden
or or not
we can't trust Russia or the United
States corporate press on this one we
can trust to a greater degree people on
the ground but then you're going to get
conflicting narratives the reality is
it's called fog of War we probably won't
know and then whoever wins is going to
tell us what we should think
that's how history Works absolutely so
here's Zero Hedge articles so former CIA
Officer says decision to draw an attack
Kremlin was made by the United States
Pharmacy intelligence Officer Larry
Johnson different Larry Johnson then
Grandmama says the decision to launch a
drone attack on the Kremlin was made by
the United States called a little lower
the Wednesday attack which was uh likely
to have been targeting Russian President
Vladimir Putin was stopped by electronic
warfare system which disabled the drones
before they could reach their target
according to Johnson the attack must
have been spearheaded by the bite
Administration and the U.S military
industrial complex because decisions on
such attacks are not are made not in
Kiev but in Washington Washington should
understand clearly that we know this
although the attack which Ukraine denied
it was involved and failed to accomplish
ITS Tactical goal it was still highly
symbolic according to Johnson can you
Google Johnson go to go to Johnson's
Wikipedia real quick let me tell you
what I do
you're in a war you're in war and you
don't want to be obvious
a false flag could be obvious
the United States says
we need to send in more money into
Ukraine how can we accomplish this for
the low low cost of two drones the U.S
stages a really ridiculous assassination
attempt Russia blows it up tricking
Russia into blaming the U.S and then
any escalation can be seen can be can be
swung or manipulated into being against
the United States giving the U.S grounds
for Casa's belly a cause for war so if
uh if Russia takes the bait and then and
they're doing it saying you the U.S did
this and they take any action against us
it gives the US what the US wants cause
for war to enter Ukraine and then they
can come to the American people every
corporate channel will say I tell you
what will happen YouTube will issue new
community guidelines saying if you
support Russian propaganda at a time of
War when the U.S is facing an
existential nuclear threat we will take
your videos down and you'll say I wonder
what that means it means if you don't
support the war there's no way YouTube
is going to let anyone have that
conversation if you try and actually
talk about what you think may be
happening
yeah but I just looked up who disguised
Larry Johnson what he's done he was with
the CI for a few years got out he's
appeared on NewsHour Larry King he's
made some comments about Obama in the
past before but Zero Hedge is a very
very credible uh uh website that a lot
of people
in many different Industries exact
Executives in the financial industry
follow what these guys have to say
anyways let's go to the next story so a
couple couple uh uh super chats I'll
read here's one from Chris Bradley 500
life expectancy in America has been
declining since the 80s in comparison to
all other Industrial in the
industrialized nations Dr Shiva is the
only U.S presidential candidate willing
to address the real issues as we Face a
nation if you're if you're if you want
your children to die sooner continue to
vote left and right if you want real
change vote vote Dr Shiva Dr Shiva was a
guy that uh got a lot of momentum during
the early stages of covid with a lot of
different names but here's a question
for you're seeing uh RFK you're seeing
vivec you're seeing different names
coming you know RFK is now in the
conversations were you know scheduling
something fantastic by the way so the
question will be what are some wild
cards that we're not even Chris Christie
says in two weeks I'm going to go in and
I know Trump is afraid of debating me
all this but who are some wild cards
that nobody is thinking out there could
be potential stars in the 2024 or we
pretty much already know who it is no
one else is going to get into it yeah I
think we know who it is you're going to
see people pop up because they want to
sell books uh I I wouldn't be surprised
if uh AOC Pops in I think it's a very
low probability for ocasio-cortez but
she's got she's famous enough is she
even 35 she will be yes and so she she
is eligible I'm pretty sure
um I'm pretty sure but uh uh I think we
know who it's going to be
um she's eligible by two weeks she's
gonna be she'll be 35 uh October 13th of
uh two weeks before election so she's 33
right now actually I think it's uh you
have to be 35 before being inaugurated
which means if her birthday was the day
before inauguration I think that would
still keep her uh very disappointed
let's live in reality right now for at
least for now yeah I think she's got 10
years
the AOC is a start doesn't mean you have
to agree with me
yeah you're right everyone laughed at
Trump and she is
if you see what will happen with an AOC
is I think the media will prop her up as
a star Democrat which which uh default
liberals they're described as would just
vote for she will capture the
progressive left in a way that no
Democrat candidate can yeah I mean come
on Biden yeah hey dude sleepy Joe is not
going to cut it this time around there's
there's no pandemic and to to keep
people uh you know locked up yeah and we
uh me and Adam had a we still haven't
bet on it because you were in Vegas you
should have done it we bet that um
besides Biden Gavin Newsom would
probably be the guy that slide in we
just had another conversation Tim I
don't want to say no names but this guy
looked at us and goes do not be
surprised if out of nowhere Michelle
Obama just goes you know what here I go
because she's denied denied denied which
one do you think is a more reasonable
like either uh Michelle or or Gavin
Gavin people think Gavin is going to be
the guy but you never know man and it is
relatively early but I I'm not so
convinced Michelle Obama would want to
do it but I do think there's a very
strong chance of winning however asked
me a year or two ago I probably would
have said Michelle Obama would win in a
landslide and I mean that figuratively
not literally I mean she'd win by like a
strong margin uh now I'm not so
convinced you know uh I I like to hang
out at the the the the casinos on the on
the weekend play poker and I'm at MGM
National Harbor this is in West Virginia
no it's a great Hotel gym National
Harbor they just built it a few years
ago it's a beautiful location beautiful
underwater incredible in Maryland oh
it's gorgeous I just stayed there it's
just south of DC but it is Maryland yeah
beautiful little area this is this is DC
this is as blue as it gets yeah that's
it in a poker table not a single person
at that table had anything nice to say
about Joe Biden or Donald Trump but they
all said I don't know man I can't vote
for Joe Biden and that felt to me kind
of like a
I don't want to say I'll vote for Trump
but I'm probably going to vote for Trump
if he's the guy because there's a lot of
that going on let me give you another
name because you live in West Virginia
you might like them you might hate them
I don't know but I'm gonna throw this
out there I actually like your Senator
Joe manchin nobody likes him in West
Virginia but how does he keep getting
elected he's not gonna guess no no no no
no no no no he's been elected for the
last 40 years he's devastated Tim
yeah he's whether or not he gets elected
for the 50th time he goes to nightclubs
we're in Joe manchinson 100 but he's
been elected as a democrat in the red
estate in the country or one of the
Reddit states of the country continually
as a Democrat how does he do it how does
he continued to do it I mean whether he
continues or not but he's done it
already the proof is in the pudding
firstly I'm in the Eastern Panhandle
which is an hour from DC 15 minutes from
Frederick big cities and it's it's like
a it's like a moderate area that leans
right and then you get into the core of
West Virginia and it is Maga country
it's 86 I mean right the people who live
around me are all die hard Trump uh
because this country used to be fairly
moderate because Democrats and you look
at Joe manchin's politics and he's
fairly conservative in a lot of ways
yeah so back when he did run I mean was
it 2018 I think he got reelected
the the country was relatively different
and people were still willing to say
yeah Democrat Republican but now you
think we've changed that much
I'm at the casino I'll punching you
right in the face right now Tim cast
there's an old guy and he's just like I
ain't drinking that and I'm like do you
even know why you're not joking that
it's just the culture wars have become
so pronounced that's why I'm saying I
think Peter thiel's wrong about DeSantis
the the hyperpolarization of this
country is is is the conversation
so I just think
I go to I go I'm hanging out West
Virginia there's not a single person I
have ever met who says they would vote
for Joe manchin you've got too many
great options you've got you James now
right now okay got you two things things
have transformed that much in the last
four years yep that's someone who's been
a democrat in mansion Maga country if
Mansion switches parties he might stand
a chance well wow yeah nice but you've
got uh Mooney who I believe is running
he's the he represents West Virginia's
first and the the Trump people love him
you have Jim Justice the governor who is
term term limited out and he's gonna run
for Senate and well they've elected him
you know to a term limit so people seem
to like him I'm not gonna pretend to
know enough uh everything about Western
Union politics I've only been here for a
couple years but just my general
understanding from being there and
talking to people we actually just went
to a dinner a republican dinner uh this
past weekend
no one there likes me not a single
person and anything nice and anything
nice to say about them they all are
gunning foreign
on your way to Miami tonight I want you
to be listening to the song country road
to the place I belong West Virginia
and this offends the people of West that
song's not about West Virginia it's
about Montgomery County Maryland
oh great
it says West Virginia so what happened
was the songwriters were driving through
Montgomery County Maryland which is on
the other side and started singing the
song Country Roads Take Me Home
to the place where I belong and then
they were like Montgomery County no that
didn't sound too good West Virginia West
Virginia yeah and it worked you have now
broken my heart twice twice in one
podcast and the one good song that I
thought was about West Virginia oh my
gosh they then went apparently the
songwriters then went back and started
doing research on so John Denver didn't
write it he performed it the uh the
writers then went back and started
researching words and and places and
things about West Virginia to put in the
song so the song is about West Virginia
it was inspired by Maryland did you hear
the room I heard a rumor too about the
whole presidential race that yeah
actually you know Pat Pat was actually
born in Iran uh that he's gonna he's
gonna be trans he's gonna self-identify
as an american-born Citizen and then run
for you what do you mean if I could
change my gender why can't he changes
if you could do like gender change why
can't he say hey I was born here so you
got my vote I identify as a natural
natural born citizen I'm announcing my
your trans here's what you do the tactic
is starting today you need to start
changing what natural born citizen means
one step at a time so what does born
even mean
porn doesn't mean when your body comes
into this world are you are you a look I
mean are you alive only after you're
born are you alive in the womb of the
Mother exactly and if you are then what
is born so born must imply then your
personal identification and experiences
so if you're naturally experiencing of
an American perspective that does mean
you're eligible friends and what does
natural mean what is anything raised
were you uh artificial intelligence how
did that happen wow this is how they uh
the gender thing is it is is Insidious
how it happens they start saying woman
doesn't mean adult human female it means
something else then when you go back to
laws that use the word woman
specifically to refer to females it now
has a different meaning because the
culture changed the meaning of the words
that's the tactic you know I always say
we did not create women's sports teams
because sometimes people wear dresses we
created women's sport teams for females
who have different bodies than males but
you see how they change the definition
of the word now a cultural you know
woman is able to play in a female
division because the words are
meaningless yeah let's change it up to a
different story and we'll come back to
RFK and a couple other Trump DeSantis
before we wrap up so Kanye West
reportedly fires extremist Nick Fuentes
from political team and uh rehires Milo
yiannopoulos after Trump dinner rift
this is a story from May 4th it's a
Forbes uh story page 14 let me go to it
here
see what Forbes has to say uh here we go
rapper and potential presidential
candidate Connie Woods has reportedly
fired White House supremacist White
House supremacist Nick Fuentes and
reinstated right-wing provocateur
provocateur Milo yiannopoulos and his
long term long shot 2024 campaign West
has also reportedly ousted Ali Alexander
2020 election dinar and organizer of the
stop the steel movement the Annapolis
allegedly sent emails to Fuentes and
Alexander informing them they were
terminated and had been
and he had been appointed director of
political operations West 2024 campaign
has been marked by stops and starts last
year he ran for president and received
only 0.04 percent the popular vote
National nationally his business Empire
collapsed after he made a series of
anti-Semitic comments uh and praised
that Adolf Hitler Annapolis Rose to
prominence as an editor but Breitbart
News but lost his job after video clips
emerge of him saying it was possible for
13-year-old boys to have perfectly
consensual sexual relations with adults
so what are your thoughts on the story
I think Miley Annapolis is a genius
he's he he is planning things that you
don't even know
and then he they are working and I am
not surprised to hear that he is once
again working with yay because I
wouldn't be surprised if this was his
plan the entire time
uh I don't know what else to say about
it I mean it feels all A bit chaotic but
you know from from what I know of Milo
from the conversations I've had with him
from what people have heard him talk
about you know this dude has a plan
you know he's doing something he's not
just sitting there throwing dartboards
at the wall he's like he's got something
going on
what is that something I don't know I
don't know I think he wants revenge on
Republic on the Republican establishment
I think he wants revenge
um for dedicating so much of his life to
Trump Maga and the conservative movement
only to be insulted and thrown out and I
think he is particularly someone who's
formidable and clearly has the means to
strike back and and be successful in
doing so I'm not saying it's like he's
guaranteed to win whatever it is he is
planning but now here he is rehired by
Kanye West whatever his plan is it seems
to be working
you define this working yeah oh yeah
Define define working what is working
because it's
if malianopolis is mad at the Republican
establishment yeah and then he gets
Kanye West Into The Fray in politics and
he gets you have a House GOP tweeted
something like uh musk Kanye Trump or
whatever and then yay goes on Alex
Jones's show and starts praising Hitler
causing damage for the Republicans like
I think he's getting his revenge in some
in some form like working is I'll put
I'll put it this way
if what he was doing wasn't working we
would not be talking about him so I
don't know what his plan is but he has
maintained his position and his
influence and his effect there you go
Kanye Elon Trump they tweeted that out
they deleted it yeah now I wonder how
much Milo had to do with that
Judiciary GOP
yeah Kanye what does that mean exactly
they were just saying like they I guess
they like these guys right Elon was
buying Twitter Trump is Trump Kanye was
speaking out in support of trump and
things like that and now because there's
a fascinating thing that occurs in this
country in in terms of what I call cult
uh cultural context
the context of the time is not praising
what Kanye said about Adolf Hitler it
doesn't matter because what the left
will do is if if you praise Kanye 10
years ago for being a great musician you
say that you think he's a genius they
will cut the date out and just take the
tweet and say you praised Kanye West how
dare you that sofa and you're like that
was 10 years ago doesn't matter doesn't
matter that was during College Dropout
yeah
I loved him not how it works they will
they they strip the context around so uh
I'll give you an example I once said uh
there's a video of me where I'm like I
don't trust the New York Times I trust
Dave Rubin right if I'm if if if I'm
looking at this in Dave Reuben I'm not
going to trust what New York Times says
what they do is they cut that particular
quote and they say look how stupid Tim
Poole is trusting Dave Rubin over New
York Times it was referring to one
specific story
now I can't remember exactly the details
but what will happen is
there will be a reporter reporting on
your life Patrick and then your friend
will come out and make a video saying
like look if I'm reading about this I
trust Patrick I don't trust the New York
Times and then they're gonna be like how
stupid of him to trust a podcaster over
over the media it's like dude the story
was about him and the job he had why
would I trust an external company about
him personally but what they do is
they'll strip out the context to make it
sound like you're speaking generally
another example is I said
there's a clip of me going Infowars is
like a right-wing Huffington Post blah
blah and then they're like Temple
actually thinks Infowars is credible
news the specific context of the story
is there were journalists on the ground
covering Donald Trump's rally their goal
is to try and capture people the way of
having to post to do like they're like a
right-wing Huffington Post so in one
specific context I'm saying this thing
they strip that out that works so what I
look again I don't I don't know what
what Milo's plan is or what yay's plan
is for that matter but if Milo is able
to get himself into the highest like
Kanye's probably the most famous guy on
the planet or one of them
he's he's got access he's doing
something you just don't know you still
know what he's doing but I mean let's
talk about what not working would be we
wouldn't be talking about it nowhere we
wouldn't know where he was and the fact
of the matter is there's probably seven
billion people you can't name whose plan
is not working
yeah that's a good point
I don't know we'll see what's going to
add a very interesting conversation with
Milo uh one time six years ago seven
years ago in Florida uh but uh you know
the guys definitely a great marketer
didn't he just start so Rob you were
telling me something about he started
called Clinic
uh yeah it's a conversion Therapy Clinic
here in Florida in Sarasota I believe
um it is a what does it do Rob I I
believe it conversion like converted
from Democrats to Republicans uh no it
comes in and slaps you in the head uh
from I believe homosexuality to
heterosexuality this is Milo let me
bringing them back let's talk about how
the media lies I had Miley Annapolis on
my show and uh and we talked about the
media says you're straight now Milo says
I never said that Milo explained that he
is a gay man who is Christian recognizes
that these behaviors and and practices
are bad so he will abstain from them and
thus be uh celibate
the media then started reporting he's
claiming he's now straight but that is
not what he said at all and so I
actually asked him I was like so you're
still attracted to men he's like yes and
I'm like okay but you're not gonna be
hooking up with me he's like no that's
wrong and I'm like oh okay so you're
celebrating he's like yes oh wow so it's
like that's a very different story to
what the media was yeah how long does
celibate last though foreign
cultural critic model yiannopoulos came
out last year last week because x gay
and is now preparing to open a
controversial conversion therapy
facility in Florida
the processor in an interview with the
post the former Breitbart News editor
revealed his plans to launch a reap what
is that reperative Therapy Clinic to
help other people go through the same
Journey as I am on myself despite the
lack of data shown effectiveness of the
exercise ask him what it hit what sense
he is ex gay Annapolis told the post
that he is an ongoing process of trying
to reorient his homosexuality but for
now is in a stage of abstinence and
enjoys using the term to troll his
critic he just tells you what he's doing
yeah exactly ex-gay right I still think
a conversion therapy plays for Democrat
the Republican is pretty funny what is a
conversion therapy place is it a strip
club is that kind of like
just a bunch of girls you're like just
like this yeah I don't know what that
was like he was working against me do
you guys consider yourselves right wing
conservative or conservative I I'm a
registered independent you know total
support of capitalist uh and
conservative beliefs when raising kids
do you are have do you bring in leftist
guests to come on the show David Pacman
was here a couple months ago
we had Jank euger we had Sam Cedar uh
five weeks ago we had Andrew yeah
Trotsky we had Andrew Yang we have uh
wow
brought him back in we actually brought
an exorcist the number one Exorcist of
the Catholic church and he talked about
how he saw body Elevate yeah
it's almost impossible for us to get
these people to come on the show
they just won't do it you had our front
desk no you know who we had all yeah
Destiny vosh we just had Lance from the
Surfs Sam Cedar wants to come on but I
think he's one of the most disingenuous
human beings in the space so like I I
should still have them on well I invited
him and then he used it against us as a
weapon so I just he's cut off got it
he's also I can tell you this I love
saying this by the way there are some
other high profile podcasts that have
completely boycotted him and he's like
complained about this not understanding
why and I know why but he's considered
widely in the space to be uh
I mean it's kind of stupid to say but
grifter we've heard similar things I'll
leave it at that I'll tell you the story
I tweeted hey we often invite leftist
guests on our show and they just don't
come on so he responded I'll come on the
show I tweeted something like it's live
in studio we'll cover your costs travel
and accommodation one works for you says
how's the 13th I say that works
perfectly so it's okay I was like We'll
DM you immediately DM him and he says
I'm not coming on your show and then I
was like okay then he goes on his show
and makes a claim against me or he's
tweeting about me and trying to back out
or something like that turning it into
some grift where he could rally his
audience you know what he did the
majority report took the song we
released only ever wanted and ran it
through a filter to make it sound bad
and then made fun of us for having bad
music like The Dude legit is fake and it
wasn't him personally it was his people
who who put a filter on our song to make
it sound bad but like that's a really
good example of what you get when you
watch someone like Sam Cedar listen
we've had a lot of people on we had a
roll of Martin on here four months ago
which was an incredible conversation
back and forth non-stop the entire time
it was uncomfortable from the second to
the last second literally but it was one
of my favorite conversations of the year
and uh
we get you know every time you have
somebody on people will text you and say
oh can I believe you're having that
person this person's this ever I've
never had anybody on
that I got that many text messages as
Sam Cedar and I don't know why people
and negative not good well so I'll I
will say
in terms of media industry stuff I don't
want to put anybody on the spot I'll
just say and Sam will probably hear this
there are high profile producers and
media people who have told me explicitly
he's blacklisted because why though
because there was this period where I
can I can speak in in one circumstance
yeah there was a period where he made a
ridiculous amount of videos about Dave
Rubin
and it got really creepy I guess I don't
know a lot about it I don't know how
many videos he made but there was a
period where people were just like this
guy's got a weird grift going on where
he just tries to do drama and the the
the perspective I suppose was
what look what happened to me when I
said hey come on the show he turns it
into drama for his audience look what
happens when I I we release a song
called only ever wanted and then his
people ran it through his weird filter
so it sounded awful and they mocked us
and insulted us like that's the fake I I
that's my experience I can only imagine
that many others had a very I mean these
all majority report Reuben clips and it
just keeps going and going and going so
let me ask you this to use the uh
metaphor that Miley Annapolis were still
talking about if he's getting names is
he kind of taking a page out of that
book Sam Cedar it's like we're talking
about him oh they're for him good for
him I don't know you know like uh but we
we the one of the best shows I think
we've ever done was just the other day
with Lance from the Surfs TV uh I think
his views are wrong I think I I think
he's wrong
but it was funny we had fun he brought a
tall boy Bud Light and cracked it open
on the show he gave his opinions which
we all like countered and then we were
laughing together I thought he was a
good friend with bad views and some
views evil
Sam Cedar sat down here and he said you
know I think you know
168. keep going how many videos are
there
but but let me but wow let me ask you
this though
when you see something like this what do
you think about when a guy's done 167
reaction videos on one person that loves
you I mean that's not a good look if you
pull up me and you pull up David Pac-Man
you're gonna find Biden and Trump
thousands of views probably and uh
that's fine if you pull up my channel
you might find a couple dozen about The
Young Turks mostly because I'll respond
to them saying something about me right
but this is like the Dave Rubin review
podcast Yeah well yeah it's crazy that's
pretty wild so so this was this is one
thing I was told explicitly that they
were like we don't know what his deal is
but wow he's got a lot of Dave Rubin
videos and that kind of is like the
perspective look he gets a lot of video
views from it he has a lot of videos
about me too I don't know how many
videos has about me
but the perception is he is not a good
faith individual trying to have a
political argument he's trying to WWE
style fan his his audience into into it
look at this like look come on look at
that look scroll up look at that picture
of me where they use Photoshop on my
face it doesn't even look like you who
is that that's you Tim Poole is a lion
coward okay you know sure whatever uh
but I will tell you though to me this is
this is look at this Temple haunted by
Thanos let me let me tell you this story
too it's a really good oh they got
another one from yesterday uh so look at
that Tim pool claims is not conservative
shredded by Lance from the service so uh
I had a conversation with Sam Cedar this
is the biggest one of the biggest
challenges for me trying to talk with
people like Sam Cedar
I say sam
um I think we're talking about
Healthcare this is years ago it's like
five years ago and actually first thing
I'll say sam Cedar was the first person
needed to ever shout me out and and and
um uh uh positively comment on my work
so shout out to Sam and uh so we're
having a conversation and I said it
sounds like your views are utilitarian
as opposed to like deontological
morality and his response was something
effective I don't know what that means
and then I'm like okay like Thanos for
instance like let me let me bring this
down to a a an analogy Thanos in
Avengers is a utilitarian I will
sacrifice half of the universe to save
the other half maximizing the amount of
good deontological morality you cannot
take an immoral action period the the
idea that you would commit an immoral
action against an individual individual
is wrong you can't cross that line
in doing so he turned it into a meme say
and then got all of his people start
tweeting at me non-stop because they
didn't understand this and I tried to
relate to them they insulted me for it
I'm like that's what Sam Cedar does
instead of having a good faith
conversation and saying I Now understand
your point or I'm sorry I don't
understand the reference he makes videos
like that
people don't people don't like it you
know what I mean like his audience might
like it it's WWE style politics and so
there's higher higher format shows that
are just like we we won't we don't
associate with this guy and I think he
knows it and I think what you're just
saying about getting those messages he
knows it and he's and he complains about
it a lot it's like bro clean your act up
and stop doing this stuff and maybe you
might find some Redemption but you know
what far be it for me to tell you to
stop doing what works if it ain't broke
don't fix it I'm sure the dude's making
a million bucks or something so let me
ask you we got a super chat here
someone's asking how much of a Super
Chat will it take for Tim to remove his
beanie what's that all about that's
because I always wear the beanie oh okay
how much of a Super Chat would it take
no it's not gonna happen I got you it's
like I don't know what that it's my
brand
do you have a beanie sponsorship we do
have someone who's making them for uh
for us but are you selling a beanie do
you sell that as a merch or no no but
everyone wants us to uh but the long
story short of it is I am bald like that
that's not a secret I don't know uh but
people say things like I wear it because
of that uh I've always worn the beanie
since I was a teenager skateboarding and
then slowly the hair starts disappearing
you know that's just what happens but I
actually met uh a guy in after Occupy
Wall Street who worked for Puff Daddy
who said to me after I got all this
press attention and I was featured in
Time Magazine he was like never lose it
never take that off
so a hundred thousand dollar Super Chat
is not gonna do it I mean I got to be
completely honest dude that doesn't move
the needle needle for me
I like
that though how many
beats but let me put it this way I love
it I've been I was invited to a I'll
just keep it some a high profile black
tie affair for the Democratic party and
I said wonderful I will show up in my
standard attire and the response was
it's a black tie affair and then I said
yes I'm gonna show up wearing a hoodie
in jeans and they said you can't come I
was like then I won't go
and I'm like what what is it worth it to
me to wear a suit to go to your your
party it's not it's not worth it would
you wear the suit but keep the beanie on
though I will never wear a suit straight
up never wear a suit it's just that's
your line of the sand suits nope they're
not happening you don't even own one I
do not own a suit I will not wear a suit
uh as formal as I will get is a vulcum
shirt with the sleeves rolled up I have
a blue one this is as most as formal as
you get this is this is fairly formal
for me thank you for dressing up in a
few hours I will be wearing shorts and a
t-shirts on a boat and flip-flops
is the beanie gonna be on the boat no no
I'm gonna be on a jet ski in the water
he's up he's off good for you but this
basically is my suit I'm not mad at it
RFK Junior let's wrap it up with rfkana
what will be done RFK Jr vows to pardon
Snowden Assange and other whistleblowers
if affected if elected RFK Democratic
presidential candidate vowed to Pardon
Julian Assange Snowden and other
whistleblowers if he's elected as
president uh the America I love doesn't
imprison imprison dissidents Kennedy
believes that the U.S actively
persecutes journalists and
whistleblowers and he intends to
investigate the corruption and crimes
they expose Wikileaks gained widespread
attention 2010 after published in a
series of leagues provided by U.S Army
intelligence analyst Chelsea Manning
revealing previously unreported
incidents involving the U.S military
killing civilians in Afghanistan and
Iraq Wars which led to criminal
investigations against the organizations
and Julian Assange what are your
thoughts on what rfk's saying here
Donald Trump Jr called into my show and
said we have to Pardon Assange and
Snowden at this point they've you know
we we know and that's a simple version
of it that is probably one of the most
important things for me in terms of who
I'm going to vote for if you put all the
presidential candidates up candidates up
on age and they all say we will not
pardon Assange and RFK says he will I'm
voting for him
is an active assassination Julian
Assange is a journalist he was falsely
accused of of uh sex crimes which were
it's fabricated garbage and nonsense
they've since been dropped they use it
as a pretext to stop him from doing the
work that he was doing because he was
exposing corruption he was running a
journalistic organization that received
leaks and then published them the same
as any other newspaper they forced him
to be uh into the Ecuadorian Embassy for
a decade where he's been slowly dying
and they tried destroying his name it is
such an egregious action of evil that uh
it's one of the most important issues to
me in terms of what someone can do now a
lot of people have said Tim to a
fundraiser for him and I'm like there's
only so much I can do in terms of the
one issue of Julian Assange but uh his
pardon is absolute and as far as I'm
concerned Snowden Snowden flip a coin
for me he should probably pardoned but
uh it's not the same Edward Snowden is
not a whistleblower he's a leaker he
grabbed a collection of documents and he
released them to the Press without
knowing what they were very very
different from blowing the whistle
Julian Assange is not a whistleblower or
a leaker he's a journalist who received
in information and then published it and
so they literally destroyed everything
that made him who he was evil to an
insane degree and it's crazy Tim how
they always use the sexual assault thing
with like with him with Andrew Tate with
Brett Kavanaugh's always like oh you did
something to a woman and nobody even
that's it there's you're finished well
they're smart right you go you go back
in time you take a look at uh Martin
Luther King Jr you take a look at JFK
and whatever you think about him they've
become immortal their ideas are their
words they have they they they can never
be stopped I think the Deep State
understood that uh whether they were
involved or not after watching that
happen saying hey you know if you kill
somebody you're gonna make him a hero
what do you got to do you gotta
character assassinate them destroy their
legs so the first thing you do is you go
for the most reprehensible because in
the United States sex crimes are
considered particularly heinous
well there you go Julian Assange is
falsely accused of rape the media then
lies in locks up with each other he's
then detained for questioning he says if
I stay here they're going to extradite
me to the United States so he fleets the
Ecuadorian Embassy lo and behold the
under Donald Trump it's Donald Trump who
did this and he was wrong to do it they
are trying to extradite Julian Assange
and so is the Biden Administration now I
asked Trump Jr will your dad pardon
Julian Assange and he says or should we
something that effect he said yes we
have to do it at this point we know
about the corruption I believe him when
Donald Trump said that the biggest
threat we face is not China it's it's
the Deep State it's the bureaucratic
it's the it's the intelligence agency
that lied to the American people you've
got this this letter that came out Joe
Biden Anthony blinken were effectively
uh Mike Morrell that they told the press
that the intelligence agency said the
hunter Biden laptop was Russian disinfo
total fabrication the intelligence
agency's former colluded to mislead the
American public these people are evil
they want power they will get it at
whatever cost they lied about Trump
every step of the way when Trump Jr says
we're going to Pardon these guys this is
what I like about a trump second term
the Revenge I believe it and I'm not
saying he's gonna like go and just be
recklessly destroying things I think
he's going to go in he's going to pull
up his tie and he's going to be like
pardon for that guy a pardon for that
guy and you're fired and you're fighting
you're fired I'll take what I can get
but I but I feel it I believe it I could
be wrong I've been I was I've been wrong
many many times when it comes to
politicians but my worst case scenario
is if Trump gets elected the world's not
going to end I think the worst case
scenario is
he built a wall he puts more fencing Up
On the Border he brings car factories to
Michigan I'm like you look at what he
did in his first term and I'm like okay
is that the worst case scenario am I
like under Biden we're looking at
nuclear war
you know you know what I like about
what's going on here's one thing I like
uh is the fact that Trump or DeSantis at
this point Trump's got a 40-point lead
35 point lead whatever the number is
these there's a couple guys that are
bringing up topics that's resonating
with voters that I think is going to be
a great case to pay attention to to run
on for 2024 vivec being one of them I
would be watching exactly uh I'd have my
guys pull up a report on the top 20
messages Vivek has given and what's
resonating the most and I would bring
him in because I think he's making very
good case on woke on ESG on Dei that
messaging is resonating there's an
audience for that I think rfk's talking
about certain things that you you can
watch and see how the audience is
reacting for that as well that can help
out for the 2024 election I think these
two guys are very important by the way
the guy that's supporting Shiva gave
another 500 wow uh uh uh what do you
call it
um this is another person apparently
that's another five years and says you
guys don't he says does pbd and TP have
the balls to host this debate or will it
be will they grift off four years later
on positive so we're saying Dr Shiva is
running for U.S president he's this
Syrian challenge to Elon Musk across on
RFK three of these to address the lies
deception and contradictions On free
speech censorship and vaccines
go forward
if someone super chats into my show and
says
you're gonna grift you're a coward why
won't you host these debates I just
scroll if someone super chats me and
says big fan of the show you have a
tremendous opportunity Dr Shiva is
fantastic please consider him I'll say
can you guys look into Shiva and see if
see what we can do there but I'm but I
want to make a point to you and I'm glad
you said that just a thought for you
Chris for you to be thinking about you
just spent a thousand hours we
appreciate it thank you it'll go into
the valuetainment fund to go make that
offer even thicker for Tucker Carlson
yeah
but this is what I will tell you I sense
a trend with people who support him him
and I had a conversation together three
years ago we got on a phone call we
talked to to I don't pull them up no no
don't pull them out Rob don't do that no
Adam don't do that to to there's there's
a part of me that I will host anybody I
will host anybody we had on Tony Brown
here disrespecting no problem I'm
curious we'll have uh uh Roland Martin
here constant from the beginning to the
end was uncomfortable no problem we'll
have a lot of different people that are
beyond that we agree with disagree with
any of that stuff we had slavo Zizek
who's a communist I had Professor from
UC Riverside or you know Riverside
Community College who's a full-blown
communist Professor there who says the
two greatest leaders of our generation
are Mao and who was the other person he
said Mom in style and I said I said if a
kid is 22 years old watching this right
now and he's aspiring one day his life
to become a major player in the world
would he be better for society to be the
next Jeff Bezos or the next Style on Mao
he says it's not even close he is better
for society to be the next Mao or Stalin
than to this is what this professor from
Riverside Community College said it's
got a million views it was one of the
best conversations we had I had who's
the guy that said we give all our
employees 70 000 a year and then tries
that thinks his name and he came out you
heard all these stories about what's
happening with them but we had him on
hour and a half conversation
it was complete opposite side
politically philosophically I said if
you're so Noble who owns 100 of your
company says I do I said if you're
really Noble why don't you give all your
employees one percent equity boom
because that's how did you ask him about
how much profit he takes the end of the
year oh we value the company on the
video and he said I said you're a rich
man he has a smirk on his face I said
why don't you give echo he says you know
what that's a good point I'll consider
it I said I said uh okay so but here's
the point as long as you're not arrogant
disrespectful you know thinking you know
it all you're above everybody else and
you can't have a civil conversation
you're just not my kind of guy man so if
you can do all the other stuff but by
the way even Sam Cedar when he came you
know what's crazy anything people said
about Sam Seed it's a I walked away said
I enjoyed the conversation until my face
he's sitting right here saying I think
you're just about there where you're too
rich and we should not allow you to get
any money above this number and then
Vinnie says so you're saying nobody
should be billionaire yeah that's what
I'm saying I think 99 tax
but the point is I think I think there's
a there's a part of persuasion it's evil
there's a part of persuasion there's a
there's a part of persuasion to use
charm Charisma to get others Vivek was
on uh one of the last shows that uh
what's his name Don Lemon oh it was
horrible please say the name correctly I
apologize he had him on the show and
they're talking and Don kept trying to
insult him
well you know as a black man I've been a
black man might as a black man look I
understand it's a philosophical
differences I have an opinion on this no
I totally can respect that he kept
saying this and saying this you know
what you made me made you think about
you're like you know what that's what
everybody can learn from on how to
handle now that's his approach Vivek
yeah okay you have to respect the fact
that he's going everywhere anyways
that's the only thing for you to be
thinking about aside from that we would
house anybody just be respectful about
your approach and uh we would be more
than happy to have the conversation with
you when you're thinking you're above
everybody you're smarter than everybody
it's just not attractive I'm I'm sure
you talked about it with the Dan price
thing came up but I really just want to
say it a lot of my friends were like oh
wow he's giving him all these salaries
to everybody and he lowered his salary
down too and I said do you know how
taxes work when you're getting passive
income profits versus salary he's
probably saving was it 7.5 percent on
social security or or Medicaid tax or
something there's a cap on it but uh I
go through this with my accountant
they're like you have to pay yourself a
reasonable salary then take profit you
can't pay yourself two less uh too
little otherwise the IRS says you're
just trying to avoid paying taxes by
taking it as profit instead of salary
but what if you do a big political
statement where you're like I'm humbly
going to reduce my salary now they can't
touch you and you're saving a like a you
know near double digit percentage in
your taxes by taking lost profit instead
of you know personal income there's many
ways to do it the way they want to do it
is punish it doesn't work when you
punish it works when you incentivize
incentives moves people punishments
don't my kids right now they both have a
straight A and Tico did not have a
straight A Dylan's his worst grade right
now is 95 you know why because he's got
such great incentive system in our
household where the progressive tax
Works backwards you get incentivized by
doing better
no no you go ahead when I was a kid we
would get five bucks for every a r
report card yeah three for every B one
for every C and nothing for D's and F's
okay and so we really wanted to get
straight A's and then we get 50 bucks we
go by Legos see and then you dropped out
at 14 years old I don't know maybe they
changed the compensation structure mom's
like you know what now we're given it
five bucks for F's and if you drop out
it's a thousand dollars I don't know
what happened there but I agree with you
like the best thing I could have done uh
uh listen you're talking to a guy that
technically was never in high school
yeah and I'm doing okay so anyways hey
uh gank listen if you enjoyed this as
much as we did looking at the numbers
here obviously the commentary you guys
love this guy uh subscribe to the
channel and not only subscribe to our
Channel Rob let's put his channel which
one do you if we have to pick one of
them which one will be the main one you
want to drive to timcast IRL
Tim cast IRL we have at the top but Rob
put it in the chat put it in description
and put it in comments gang go subscribe
uh to Tim's YouTube channel on top of
that Tim's got a book as well uh the
tales from the inverted World ghosts of
Civil War as well as well as a new song
that just came out Bright Eyes that's
available on iTunes Amazon and Spotify
we have all of that in the description
for you to give uh for you to go find uh
but this was a blast man the book is by
Shane Cashman okay and he went down
looking for the Lost Confederate gold
and so we we our company released it but
uh shout out to Shane who's the author
and and the adventurer who went and it's
crazy published it it's written by Shane
written by Shane published we're gonna
put that there as well Tim uh good
having you on bro absolutely this was
great thank you have a great weekend
we'll do this again next week take care
bye-bye